is Wednesday we are going entirely off
the rails today because I'll tell you
who's not here the rail guards
Dan is out for the rest of the week he's
at a wedding
you're gonna need more enthusiasm than
that AV
a okay okay a little more can is there
more intensity or no he looks like yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's good
that's good so Amy's filling in for Dan
she's Chris he's okay you okay yeah it's
not easy yeah it's not it's not it's not
easy not easy yeah so uh it is November
20th thank you everybody for being here
today I feel uh Qatari yes
today I feel disabled
today I feel I felt game
may Allah awaken the people
I'm drunk that's the game I'm playing oh
no not the kingdom I guarantee you got
some five plus no that girl came from
stupid people
satisfied no Leonardo DiCaprio
I'm at this high school girl God is
strong tonight
[Music]
got him
and that is keemstar of course dancing
to retirement
or I heard some people say Kim that's
keemstar when he shows up uh
at high school recess I don't know yo
bro I'm at this high school girl that I
was hot as [ __ ] so yeah I mean his word
is not mine right verbatim that's what
he said that makes sense but anyway
thank you everybody we got a great great
show planned here today
um made segment for the day is one we've
been working on for a while
influencer product reviews we have
a tier list of 24 influencer products to
go through
most of them are here in the studio some
are going to arrive some are yet to
arrive so we'll have to amend this
there's a few that I really want to
review that haven't arrived yet but
we've got a whole table a whole spread
here
and uh boy am I excited to bust into
that
[Music]
um
so that's fun we've also got the liver
King friend of the show was brutally
exposed oh
you know people are joking like oh wow
that's that's shocking liver Kings on
steroids
it's not just that he's on steroids like
most of us suspected he's on stairs it's
the amount of steroids
he was on twelve thousand dollars worth
of steroids a month now I don't know how
much normal steroid users use but I
can't imagine many people can afford
twelve thousand dollars a month of
steroids that's all twelve thousand a
month bro that's insane this [ __ ] was
spending like what 140 000 a year on
steroids
yeah that's insane
so um we have a whole list of everything
he's been on and actually
we're having
um
friend of the show PNP our favorite
attorney
let's go coming in because I want to ask
him
is this like fraud in a way
it may be some kind of a legal marketing
if he's saying his products got him to
look like that but he's on twelve
thousand dollars worth of steroids I
think it's an interesting question
you're not actually trying to defraud
people yeah yeah no it's identity theft
actually what he's trying to do it's
interesting
I'm seeing anywhere from 100 to 800 a
month okay so this guy is on some wild
and it also says is if it costs more
than a thousand it means you're doing a
bunch of blood work or oh you have extra
steroids he he was doing a lot of blood
work and everything
oh that story it just it kind of it
really upsets me because he was on on
this all this [ __ ] about how
cholesterol is [ __ ] cholesterol is a
a conspiracy
and meanwhile he's in the background
checking all that [ __ ] with his doctor
and it's just he's like he's knowingly
selling
Health misinformation it's [ __ ] up man
um
you know and and Cam's been on those
goddamn 18 pills a day and I mean he's
not looking anymore jacked uh cam what's
going on back there yeah my abs aren't
as as popping as his so I gotta start
doing steroids too I think dude I need
your abs look like cantaloupes yeah let
me get uh you got 12K for me I'll start
the cycle right now
that could be interesting experiment
actually uh never mind I could I could I
might be able to fund that for you [ __ ]
hey you're out fast huh
yeah don't challenge me and you know I'm
willing to spend money out for the show
how are you going to milk and Hope
uh tomorrow is our December Teddy fresh
drop I'm actually wearing this shirt
right now and I love this shirt looks so
nice
I love this [ __ ] it's like wearable
classy but still fun and exciting
it's just a taste of some stuff coming
out tomorrow 10 a.m PST of course this
is the jacket I was wearing the other
day
love that jacket so much
uh turtleneck Vibes Hassan's been
wanting a turtleneck the turtle Teddy
fresh turtleneck I love it there you go
I think he already has this one this is
like a re-issue of all right he has the
green one yeah yeah got it best
uh this sweater is nuts dude
yeah it's crazy
this is the one that ELO was wearing
with the jewels
um we're actually selling a teddy fresh
rug
looks awesome
that is really cool
super clean this is the Gary Kennedy
sweaters are coming out tomorrow with
the dogs
and uh this and actually so much more
stuff so check out the website tomorrow
at 10 A.M thank you thank you
PST of course
Henry donated
170 New Zealand dollars for Cameron
he says this is for your steroid
rotation yeah I think going to good use
thank you very much he said cam you're
my fave this is for you thank you very
much that's nice
I'll also also also before we get into
it
um
last this is the last week to buy the H3
trading cards all proceeds go
to the crew
and actually you guys we made a um
a fantastic promo video for you guys to
enjoy here so
this is good enjoy things are looking
dicey my Ela and my Zach are both tapped
locked into a defensive position my ab's
burrito and my family's card are both in
the graveyard ah no way out he's got a
Hot Chip Lena which obviously counters
my grass type can in his Swedish love
card completely overpowers my leftovers
and he has the shredder and Alfredo
enhancement cart I'm done kaput blammo
finished you ain't got [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's only one card that I could draw
that could get me out of this situation
right now I need to trust in the heart
of the cards I've only got one shot here
we go time to fly
foreign
[Music]
cards available now on TR
dng.shop sale ends December 3rd there it
is you guys the trading cards of a
lifetime
get them while you can the crew will
thank you
100 goes to them and you will be humored
you know what I love about making that
ad was Ian was feeding the lines and
then each time Zach would be like okay
got you and then improvise every line
made it a lot better dude that's what
I'm saying I'm the same way Zach that's
how it's done you can you know you got
to make it your own exactly
is he a diva in is he hard to work with
no I mean he's sort of a Day Lewis type
yeah I think he was in the role but I
would be like okay Zach say that say why
are you laughing and go got it why are
you humored every lying hey right no
dude he's a superstar yeah you're a
natural kid stack is a natural thank you
thank you we'll love that for you
so there's that
thank you thank you
um also want to say thank you to all of
our members we had a banger members only
live stream I think a lot of people are
under the impression that the LA that
the members only episode see you next
Tuesday which happens every Tuesday is
still Audio Only that's not the case
it's actually video audio and it's live
every every Tuesday and here
as opposed from the subreddit I thought
was you know compelling members know
that Tuesday is the real off the rails
and that's true it's just me in the
basement live and nobody's there to tell
me you know so much so in fact
I just remembered that Trisha said she
looks like Samuel Jackson and I always
thought that was so funny so I took I
just you know I went in Photoshop but
put my skills to the test and I actually
overlaid Samuel Jackson over a picture
of her and it's insane the strikingness
it was absolutely nuts I mean I'm she
does look like Samuel Jackson and we
proved that mathematically on Tuesday
uh it was a lot of fun so thank you all
the members who were there
yeah it was off the rails you leaked our
text messages yes I leaked my WhatsApp
luckily nothing sensitive was on there
but everybody was blowing me up Dan was
trying to keep me on the rails he was
texting me he's like non-stop of the
show trying to warn me [ __ ]
but uh we made it through no no
catastrophe
I'm actually starting to really enjoy
those Tuesday UPS fun
so there that is
also I really want to say
my heart goes out to Jay Leno you know
he
we kid Jay Leno uh
he got brutally burned in an accident
and as you guys know we
never make fun of Jay Leno in fact we
have
only the deepest of condolences
he was in that hyperbaric chamber which
is now on Wiki feet which is like shame
on you
why would you put a picture of a man in
a hyperbaric chamber on wikiFeet
so tasteless
you know what I mean like have some
respect for his privacy dude
here it is I mean what the [ __ ] is wrong
with y'all look at this [ __ ] it's all
covered in rags and he's on fire and
here you are looking at his feet
oh wow somebody really went deep on this
look at this one
that's crazy these wikiFeet people are
on another level man I'm telling you
yeah well unfortunately Jay just got out
of the hospital and he's already gotten
into another car crash
you believe this guy's luck take a look
the cop car A Cop Car Nola
yeah the cops don't care though they
give him a pass he they give him the
cavcaf pass you know what I mean
come on Jay hit the cop car oh boy tight
squeeze
oh boy no Jay numb back up
oh
maybe the burn got to through his brain
I don't know tight squeeze tight squeeze
I gotta say though not easy to parallel
park with a hundred people filming you
you know what I mean
that's got to be stressful here he gets
out of the car
hey he looks fine how does it feel to be
back on stage
elephant you know what's funny he looks
like the Elephant Man before the burns
he literally has the facial structure
Elephant Man
like he's making I'm you know like
seriously Elephant Man
I am not an animal all right
I mean talk show host
he does he's got like a big ass forehead
and Chin like he is giving Elephant Man
John Merrick Jay Leno
I don't know who's this guy yeah and the
peace and love to this guy I didn't
realize there was a modern day Elephant
Man
he's staying positive though
according the headline modern day Alpha
Man from Riverside tries to stay
positive
so we wish him the best stay positive
out there brother
you you mean
but but here's a here's the la-based
Elephant Man back I'm not
lost some weight I was nervous about
coming out James now stay away from the
floor dude he looks great he is flame
[ __ ] he looks fantastic I'll bet you
it's the hyperbaric chamber it
youngins you you know what it's like he
basically no I'm with you I was trying
to say it makes you younger but I almost
said it euthanizes I get it that's
that's the op euthanize oh euthanasia
yeah yeah I gotcha you know what all it
did we it was just like one of those
flame chemical appeals that we looked at
the other day skin came off and he was
shining underneath man after
yeah it was just his tire that wasn't
just his tire let's be honest but anyway
we wouldn't we wouldn't a kid
um
we wouldn't kid Jay Leno we only wish
him the best
and I'm happy that he's looking good and
uh I just wanted to say that this is not
by the way that was a scratch not a pick
I just want to let you guys know
scratch anyway yeah so we wish him well
yeah people got upset I mean we're
sincere we we feel bad it was uh maybe a
little far
yeah yeah well okay all right
yeah
foreign
[Music]
Zach never saw this
[ __ ] oh Zach loved that
that was my entry for you laugh you lose
you never saw that eh Masterpiece Zach
was sick give me the hot chick man I
laughed
yeah well we weren't supposed to I was
trying to wish him well I was trying to
say that we wouldn't make fun of him and
then
I didn't mean for that to play I'm sorry
that was a slip of the hand and uh I do
apologize to the Leno family for that
I'm glad you enjoyed that I worked you
know I I felt good about that I got Dan
good with that one that might be the
funniest [ __ ] I've ever seen
thank you so much
it's been a while since I tested my
chops that uh like that I still got it
apparently
I still got it it just keeps going yeah
yeah
oh man did you say you want a hot chip
because no I was making a joke you sure
we have I lost I'll take it with you I'm
cool brother I'll take a hot tip any day
I don't fear that thing Lena
Hot Chip nope just for fun yeah just for
fun no thank you see what happens
or a ring of fire Showdown is next
Monday okay let's you hear that Lena
next Monday is the ring of fire Showdown
meaning we're all gonna do it again well
whoever's whoever's you know
feeling uh bold and courageous
okay I'm in for sure okay yeah other
people are going to be doing it I'm
doing it is I believe Dan is 100 doing
it are you saying that jokingly
nope
the way you well Dan's the current
leader so he really should do it and
he's obviously he's probably watching
from his hotel room or something but we
can count him in according to Ian so
that's good a b
no thank you
oh ela's doing it
all right you said she'd do it yeah
I'm afraid I'm curious to see how that
goes I'm scared for but I appreciate how
uh Fearless she is
you know ninja
uh the the famous video game player we
tried to
video game player what else gamer twitch
streamer I guess the Boomer in me came
out no I like to keep it going
he's a video game player
he plays yeah anyway
we've been trying to make amends with
him and I felt that we had come a pretty
far way to you know building a bridge
between our two worlds
and apparently I took things too far
when I made fun of Elon Musk
and he was like that's not a joke he
said to me right is that what he said uh
Zach comedy was alive and well I mean he
says that's not funny right it's not
funny yeah it's not funny he said
funny it's not funny what I did it's not
it's not funny it's not a joke it's not
funny he's so angry so here's ninja by
the way
and you know there's there's a big
problem going on right now lots of
anti-Semitism coming out in the open
from people like Kanye West
Nick Fuentes and all these people you
know getting so much attention in the
media now what you would think you know
now is a good time not to be making
anti-semitic comments but then crash cut
to ninja
the fortnite player
uh go ahead roll it
my Jewish I'm not
although my nose is [ __ ] massive
that is not funny that is not funny it
is not a joke
it's not funny ninja
who authorized you to be dropping
anti-semitic uh tropes like that brother
it's not funny
I thought comedy was dead and uh gone or
whatever
no but on seriousness that's a little
bit off the [ __ ] cuff isn't it it's a
little bit like yeah casual
anti-Semitism I'm not defending him but
we can't see the chat I'm curious what
the actual comment said if it was just
are you Jewish because that's insane on
its own but if you said if you ever made
a comment about his notes and then asked
him if he's being Jewish he should have
still pushed back obviously but yeah I
see what you're saying you're saying did
they ask about his nose yeah okay is
there a way to find that out am I Jewish
I'm not Jewish
I'm guessing he deleted this one
although my nose is [ __ ] massive I
thought comedy wasn't that doesn't make
sense he's definitely just saying that
someone just said are you Jewish yeah
I thought it was free speech to say
empathize semitism actually it is free
speech
so there you go
there is champion of free speech
um Ninja
[Applause]
and let me just say Blevins is a [ __ ]
weird name bro while we're talking about
it like BL there's you need a you need a
a uh what are those called the a the
vowel vowels right yeah
elevens you're missing something blue
it's like dude what
it's weapons idiot
Thomas stupid [ __ ] idiot with your
beloved it's your garbage garbage
fortnite player what's his ethnicity
fortnite
player uh Ninja skin
let's see where you're from
you wish not that I would ever make fun
of someone's ethnicity well I was from
Michigan Detroit did you know that he's
Welsh oh he is yeah okay I've always
wondered why he's a lions fan because
they're not the best team so I did find
it interesting yeah he's from Detroit
so you guys are brothers kind of huh
he's always wearing Detroit Lions
yeah but they're not the best team
so so you you would need a reason to be
a fan right right like when I wore the
Detroit Red Wings Jersey and everyone's
like why are you wearing that I think
we're going to be good yeah anyways yeah
so let's see punch
Jewish
and uh still no apology to Pokemon no
Paul due to Pokemon and now I'mma need
apology yeah put that up love that's a
frame of a frame ninja I'ma need apology
bro because let's be honest after you
simp for Elon Musk
after I I had made such great efforts to
be this guy's friend
you know I went so far and I had this
whole Redemption Arc I was trying and
ninja basically spit my face
and it's it is it's halt in my entire
Redemption Arc I am back to a hateful
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] thanks to you
anti-semite
why don't you just go on tour with Kanye
West while you're at it
yeah
ninjas one loss in Fortnight away from
saying how many
the numbers are greatly exaggerated he's
one loss away you know what I'm saying
God damn bro
it's not funny it's not a joke
now what
but it is kind of funny how he got so
mad over what I said
a stupid joke about Elon and then he's
out here being like Jews have big nose
and they're greedy and they control the
world oh really Ninja
okay my nose is [ __ ] massive he
didn't say those
yeah to be clear he didn't he just said
no I'm joke I'm making it yeah
there's a lot of clips of him saying
weird [ __ ] from the past too so you we
know for a fact that he this is not uh
irregular from him it's adding up you
think oh yeah really what has he said in
the past I actually hear the
controversies
well I don't know if you've said
anything racist necessarily but he's
just been like generally very weird
actually I do think I do think I saw
some races oh wait this is actually just
Ninja
this is just a page about ninjas
right
right right
you know just typical gaming Lango
hold on I did see
and uh let's see in December 2016 blevin
here I can't read that [ __ ] it's too far
away
I'll read it to you guys
oh no Blevins released the address of a
donor as retribution for having a racist
screen name oh he docks one of his
donors the f
oh no he said the n-word once while
rapping a song
oh no I also found ninja apologizes
after using racial
on stream well you know what where's the
Juno's apology bro yeah said it's my
stream and it's on me to make that right
yeah well it's your stream make it right
dude
you know my people didn't [ __ ] die
for this [ __ ]
thank you
you know what I mean am I Jewish this
dude is one Fortnight loss away from
picking up mineconf at this point his
[ __ ] struggles are real
so are mine man you think it's easy but
comedy was alive and well
uh
on a serious note though nobody's gonna
care nobody's gonna say [ __ ] this isn't
going to become a story because nobody
gives a [ __ ] about anti-Semitism for the
most part this is like subtle
anti-Semitism right
very low grade I mean obviously when
Kanye is like Defcon 3 on all Jewish
people
then that gets picked up
yeah just making a small joke like that
or whatever could you do that on a
different minority
Arabs okay yeah we yeah Jimmy does that
well Jimmy's on cancelable but yeah
but just his fans are very young and
they don't really know the meaning
behind that joke so they might just
repeat it without you know thinking
about it yeah I feel like when you're
taught about anti-Semitism that's like
the example of what anti-Semitism is I
feel like
it's a stereotype that is a little known
to be poisonous at this point I could
literally stay anti-semitic [ __ ] and
they can't drop me
love that
love that yeah I mean it's it's the
picture you know of the greedy Jew and
the big nose and all that stuff but I
you know what's funny I haven't really
found Jews to have big noses like other
people that I know I mean you know
but there it is uh Ninja is a Nazi
confirmed no I'm just kidding
get can you find his PO Box let's send
him a tiki torch
no uh oh okay no no we won't do that
don't do that where's that button
nevermind that's a joke come on stop he
doesn't even have a PO Box probably I
don't even know if he does no he doesn't
yeah
although my nose did you watch the uh
Dave Chappelle monologue on SNL I did
what did you think of it
I thought that it was
not terrible but at the same time
I don't know a little [ __ ] like
it I don't know it's like really dude
and sometimes it's like do you really
because the thing is
like with the Trans people it's like
it's not super funny to joke about
people who are on already the receiving
end of all the [ __ ] right like that's
not
in my opinion the height of what comedy
is like the best kind of Comedy
I'm not and I'm not the Arbiter of
Comedy but I'll speak for myself it's
like
you speaking truth to power right and
you know being like the Jews control the
media or and [ __ ] like that he's
basically in a way co-signing what
Kanye's been saying and a funny and kind
of light-hearted way
that uh again punching down is all he's
doing and it's all he's been doing and
it's like
it makes it hard to cheerlead for him
you know uh it's it's like okay nice
dude How brave of you to [ __ ]
I don't know right bully people they're
already being bullied basically it's
it's sad because I I loved Dave
Chappelle growing up you know one of my
first videos that I made sketches were
like based off of his
um
but yeah there's no defending recent
stuff and I was just curious because I I
have a Jewish friend in the family who
uh who said that he was more offended by
Chappelle than Kanye because at least
Kanye's insane and Chappelle is just
normalizing him so I was just curious
what your take was no I I disagree with
that personally I understand where he's
coming from Kanye is like actually
putting anti-Semitism on the map it's
crazy hey
come come get me
but you're right in a way it's more
Insidious he has a point what Chappelle
does because he makes it like uh kind of
okay
in a more way I don't know what's with
him but dude it's like
[ __ ] man
he he lost his I don't know what
happened it's like your brain on
conservative they lose their [ __ ]
mind dude
I think what happens is like
he made some in the beginning he made
some jokes about trans people that was
like I in my opinion not that bad it was
it was funny whatever and then when
there starts to be a strong reaction he
finds Solace and even more conservative
people
and they become his people they become
his group they egg him on they make him
feel safe yeah and he goes deep he
spirals deeper and deeper and deeper and
I you know there was a time in my career
where that where I saw that happening to
me
and which is why I made a hard pivot to
get out of the vortex
um
yeah people are saying I I said Dan's at
a wedding but actually the truth is that
he uh the quartering made him an offer
he couldn't refuse and uh
he's part of the quarterings team now
he's mopping up year in in the basement
there and well he's paying him a lot so
that's right
yeah
um we've got some super chats here you
look very good oh thank you I love super
chats like that thank you kleina
mon yogan
and uh one from
God damn it
seems so hard to navigate Bella Simmons
Legend it's bizarre to me the
anti-Semitism isn't acknowledged part of
my seventh grade curriculum was reading
Night by Ellie weisel
and that ingrained the reality of it and
this was me growing up in rural 6400 DPI
Jesus dude sorry
the chat was asking I didn't know how to
do it I'm still trying to do it for like
two minutes and I just got it so there
you go but what's the DPI at uh it is
8200 DPI that seems really high yeah
well I can handle it oh Dan can not in
the shower you can't right thank you
1400 DPI thank you for the gift Sir
George thank you for the gifts
yeah and so um
yeah that's my thoughts
you know
[Music]
he should join The Clique with Ninja
play around a fortnight together
um
also my heart goes out to Wendy Williams
you know we were the biggest Wendy
Williams Show fans and her sound bites
were frequent entries into the final did
they ever win
Wendy Williams How much of the sound
came close
um I don't think they won though but she
she's honestly been an inspiration to me
for a long time and I'm just so sorry to
see kind of whatever's going on with her
here is a little clip that came out
recently
how you doing you're looking good thank
you
somebody's hands somebody come here
she's Louise what
[Music]
yeah I don't know what how did she I
don't know what's wrong or what's going
on but she declined so fast
she was just doing the show not that
long ago you know
yeah yeah the farting the burping
I missed the good times man should she
suffer
yeah she has lymphedema some people
speculate she may have dementia and she
hasn't said that she has dementia but
but she's way too young for dementia
when I know you can have early onset
like Alzheimer's I've heard of that I
don't think she has Alzheimer's but
maybe she does Wendy Williams age I mean
how old is she
she's only 58 for pizza's sake man
I mean yeah I've heard of early onset
Alzheimer's that [ __ ] is so sad bro
I'm like trying to find out uh
the rise uh the risk Rises after 65. so
she's not even 65. I know that the thing
she complains the most about is her feet
she said that it's like very difficult
for her to walk because it's just so
painful oh I think that's a lymphedema
making her uh
I can't remember but yeah I think that's
what's causing the swelling and also she
has Graves disease which is why her eyes
are all like
going big like that well let's try to
keep her out of the grave
and send her our best wishes
all the best
yeah it says ER it says early onset
Alzheimer's can hit people as early as
in their 40s and 50s that's terrifying
and so so sad
oh brother
oh
God when are we gonna fix that [ __ ] when
are we gonna cure that [ __ ] man
hopefully soon horrible
now
all right
um also one of my favorite videos on the
internet all the time this is just top
of the show stuff we're working through
there folks
we gotta Lube you up you know what I
mean before I go in I don't want to go
and dry yeah
and so
one of my favorite Clips is of
a player or a first aid guy he was
trying to pick up an injured soccer
player and he kept lifting his face
right into his [ __ ] and it's very
funny and so we got a somewhat of a
of a good similar one here
let's take a look got him if you weren't
injured now you are [ __ ]
that's a good one I like that he
probably flopped so that guy just was
like come on dude
you know what he did you just literally
kicked the dude who probably gets paid
like 50 million dollars a year in the
face and riska injury
love that
so there that is
um here's the ones that I love just just
to remind you guys
you know
[Laughter]
that one's good that one is good
you know this isn't the one
that I love
but it is good this one doesn't get
claimed no I didn't
seems like something be claimed City
whatever but this is my favorite is this
the one yeah this oh my God these videos
nothing better than this is
oh this isn't the one this isn't the one
that's funny but it's not the one I was
thinking of
Gladstone
bro just turn around oh no is that the
kid they really put his ass on blast huh
dude soccer is crazy they can get that
kid killed putting him out like that
soccer fans are crazy as a [ __ ]
[Music]
together you go man
[Applause]
also coming off of our keemstar Bonanza
did he say anything other than this in
the one clip where he said I hate our
fans I haven't checked this morning but
as of yesterday that was the most recent
man he's really different
he's really defeated if he hasn't you
know what I mean yeah
put out 20 Twitter vids about it but
this is one that we thought was pretty
fun I think you guys will enjoy
he liked a tweet from this user that
says about me he's always been an
arrogant piece of [ __ ] who hides behind
his Tourette's
that's when I've never heard actually so
that's a first so I appreciate that from
keemstar
um we just had that idea the other other
day yeah we for the first time we
uttered that joke again and I don't know
maybe they saw that and didn't doesn't
watch us but I find it find it so
interesting that I he says I hide behind
my Tourette's
he tweeted Beau Black's hates Jews he
just pleaded that straight up
Beau blocks is that true
thank you for the gift to George
actually we're gonna honor Beau blacks
later in the show Beau blocks is a
friend of the show turns out
uh mousey says wishing me luck getting
this job I just interviewed so I have
money for more Super chats well I can
spend the money elsewhere but thank you
so much and good luck
uh he hasn't tweeted about me but he
pinned a comment saying that I'd be word
the V City no he pinned his tweet with
the clip with his feeties no no the
toesies no the new one he deleted the
toesies the HD clip
good for him man
happy for him or some [ __ ] like that
makes sense I'm gonna try to do better
with the Tourette's thing imma own up
I'm gonna start owning my mistakes and
not using Tourette's as an excuse
thank you Kim for that dose of reality I
needed here's another one cam you so cam
you missed the you laugh you lose
but you have an entry you're very
passionate about you want us to watch I
don't know if I'm very passionate about
it but I thought you guys would get a
kick out of it you know I I curate a lot
of strange things that pop up on my Tick
Tock for you page and I thought you guys
would laugh at this but uh it's a shame
that Dan's not here because I know he's
a uh curator of cringe himself so I hope
Dan sees us eventually he'll see it he's
probably watching hi Dan yeah hey Dan
all right so here's Cam's anyone who
laughs has to take a bite of spicy chip
just one no you can you don't feel
like you don't have to laugh I don't
know
but enjoy I think I want to eat some
spicy chip yeah keep bringing it go for
it like I can't do it by myself
what do you have these are rare gems
that have popped up on my for you page
and a friend of mine also sent me a
couple too okay here we go this will be
fun and exciting times
[Music]
and aliens and all kinds of [ __ ] like
that wake up wake up wake up wake up
wake hi I'm Tom from Minnesota and I
want to know who wants to play reindeer
games
what dude what a weirdo
why would you post that
maybe it's you
you're not getting that guy's car here
close by where I grew up in uh be
looking for that on my YouTube channel
um the link for that is in my bio if you
haven't already check my channel out but
if not go to it you might learn
something I don't know I'm sure we will
can we find his video I mean cam can you
get us a link to that I'll look into it
yeah yeah I mean that was quite a plug
I'm actually interested though
thank you Katie cat meow five gifted sub
uses
um pineapple sandwiches oh the legends
on one side and they this is the real
life version of the pedo guy from Family
Guy come on over here Chris so there get
your little Cam and I have have such
dove into the history of this guy his
name is Kenneth Lee Anderson yeah
and we know everything about that man we
thought he was dead for a bit but it
turns out he's still alive yeah he's
still kicking yep
best believe me let's see what he says
we just spread your mayonnaise on one
side and they
slices of pineapple on top and close
your bread and there's your sandwich
delicious
now listen everybody
[Music]
what the hell dude
where's all the [ __ ] real women
that's the whole Tick Tock where's all
the real women oh my goodness after his
cough what uh yeah this is just the
magic of uh tick tock's for you page
what a ladies man do you drink oil
somebody asked him
you missed his uh oh let me go back
yeah apparently
do you smell farts
oh my God
See you ladies I got a whole bag full of
Cutlery knives
laughs and I got this one today wow
anybody want to [ __ ] me oh my God
Jesus Christ man I can't believe we
occupy the same spaces as people and no
no hate that he's like
some of these people feel like they're
just like
a different species almost like God damn
dude like that couple that had a a dog
bed in the living room or a doggy cage
in the living room for the husband
y'all remember them they were wild these
people vote again and they all vote for
Trump yeah by the way
Trump's my God
mm-hmm
who wants some cutlery
America
who wants some Cutlery in my kitchen I'm
voting Trump
[Music]
dude what is going on oh my God
holy [ __ ]
dude first of all her car is must be
it must not have a tire or something
listen to this the sound of that baby
run
that woman is 100 voting Trump
she will see you at the polls
[Music]
someone said Ethan brings politics into
everything shut the [ __ ] up dude
got him
[ __ ] dumbass what am I supposed not
to care about it I'm just saying it's
something that comes to my mind
because it's in everything just saying
I'm trying to make I don't barely talk
about politics but uh
I'm just saying bro you know she bought
Trump you sound like a trump voter
thank you Freedom we got
you know enjoy your freedom hold body
never take away from you or grilled
cheese Pelosi she thinks she's gonna
hold us holder that's boomhauer's
grandfather this [ __ ] is on
oxygen why is it going to bring politics
into everything dude yeah exactly yeah
this motherfucker's talking about
Freedom Joe Biden take away come on dude
I mentioned Trump once in the show and
people bitching
president Trump if you see this please
save us
this guy might be my fave right here I
love the oxygen
and the obviously drinking while driving
is powerful too but this guy's a this
guy's a picture of health of good health
it's like a white version of ollip
looks like kind of interesting
Congress when you enjoying that freedom
we got we got that freedom you enjoy
your freedom hold body never take away
from you or grilled cheese Pelosi thinks
she's gonna hold us hold her hold a
Connery
that's crazy that they've somehow I'm
they've convinced these people to hate
Joe Biden and Nancy Pelosi these
[ __ ] don't know
what's going on outside their truck I
mean demands on oxygen is you know what
I mean uh how the [ __ ] are you gonna
have an opinion about that no dude
they're trying to take away his freedom
to drink and drive dude I like his
theory on freedom is like if you don't
use it you lose it
if you don't be drinking while you're
driving man they're gonna take that
freedom away boy tell you what
hit me with that Oxygen Bar
oh I can't breathe hit me with that
oxygen oh thank you brother
foreign
you know what
it was a less laugh out loud funny and I
was just really captivated by it all to
be honest with you it gets all prettied
up and they load up Coleman's hair all
went out there get on off that with the
freedom and it's a bit of oxygen and to
drink it on the beer man or a nasty blow
see that grilled cheese Nancy Pelosi man
you're gonna take that freedom with that
little old legs
man boom and a little old Nancy Pelosi
man your body be taking a freedom
weighted oxygen out of it
that reindeer games one was my favorite
I thought you were like that that one
was very good
some weird people out this world man no
I'm not defending Nancy Pelosi or even
Joe Biden but I just find it funny that
they somehow are so passionate about
that [ __ ]
that's a big game man you know
Amanda thank you for the five gifted
appreciate you
all right so we have PNP lined up to
comment on this liver King thing so
let's do that first and then and then
we'll move on to the influencer product
segment
yeah so friend of the show
liver King
was caught leaked
his steroid regiment
[Music]
Al and this guy's whole shtick is
basically
total [ __ ] and again we knew that
but we didn't
it's first of all it's good to know it
because there was still people debating
though he was so emphatic about not
taking steroids
that a lot of people were like [ __ ] you
know I don't know is he it does he or
doesn't he but this guy more plates more
dates
okay
how are you gonna milk an oat uh somehow
got a hold of emails
that he had actually sent him because he
was a
bodybuilding coach back in the day
and also
how do you get these emails was it sent
to a bodybuilding coach who leaked it
who found them in his emails I'm
assuming that's how it happened yes so
old emails right so he he got these
emails from a year ago as liver King was
taking off but also coincidentally uh in
the video he mentions while he was going
through the emails he saw there was an
email from liver King to Derek from this
channel yeah so
I want to give credit to this guy who
did this his name is uh more plates more
dates
and there you go I mean that that's
that's good advice better than um Andrew
Tate I guess more plays more dates
um is that true or play some more dates
I don't know what have you got what do
the ladies things
it's basic math
what is that like more muscles yeah yeah
yeah more lifting more I think more
gains yeah more gains no not necessarily
I mean you're in the Pete David yeah
Pete Davis has like zero percent body
fat though but also Emma I'm kind of
offbeat Davidson right now really yeah
what happened
Emily
yeah and um she's beautiful and amazing
and I think that I'm just it's too much
it's too much you can't even fantasize
about it anymore it's there's too much
content out there that he's giving us
that I'm just like I don't want to
participate aren't you getting a little
turn off by just how clout [ __ ] he is
like the man he goes I'm not dating any
more famous woman and then he
immediately goes on to date Emily
radajowski right but if I feel like if
if you were a young single person and
people who were like these women that
he's pulling were interested you'd be
like I mean
who am I to say no no yeah definitely
definitely that's that's true I mean not
many of Among Us would pass on that
um here he shows more plates more dates
you guys can watch the whole video here
it's an hour long um but here he shows a
compilation of liver King denying taking
steroids so many times in his mid-40s
and traveling constantly and having more
on his plate than ever from a
entrepreneurship perspective in an
effort to maintain full transparency
just like he does with his supposed
natural status liver King has been very
candid about the success of his
portfolio of supplement companies my
little birdie told me that you're making
over 100 million dollars a year from
your businesses
true or false true true that's that's a
pretty staggering staggering
accomplishment Now understand who the
[ __ ] is buying that [ __ ] bro like
legitimately is this worth watching this
success I think it's good I think it's a
good setup for everything it's how
adamant how much money he's making of it
so you see it's not just that he was
lying about it he's because he's rob you
know he's robbing people for nature was
claims of being natural and his brand as
a whole as there is a clear monetary
incentive to promote what he does and if
he's on drugs after all there is a clear
monetary incentive to withhold that
information from the public and lie
about it to push his agenda and this
scrutiny has compounded exponentially
over the past year as liver king is not
just not just double down on his
statements of claiming natural but he
has literally a hundred folded down on
it on several of the biggest podcasts in
the world regardless of whether you use
stuff or not like
I don't can they get a build like yours
without taking them so I want to set the
record straight I want to expand and
tell you why it's possible a year ago
maybe two years ago it was all about
like Peds and steroids right and and
then you know same question same answer
I didn't touch the stuff don't touch the
stuff right Joe Rogan criticized you Joe
Rogan's a big person in terms of his
platform how did that feel when he said
he alluded that you're on steroids or
something like that yeah number one I
don't do it and number two what I want
you to say is you know what I don't know
I don't know I mean that guy in fact he
did say he's in the
.0001 percent of genetics if he does it
naturally what is the liver cancer yeah
liver King saw that as so you're saying
it's possible
it's that uh there's a scene from Dumb
and Dumber that I love so much oh yeah
you're saying there's a chance she says
what was the line she said I always
loved that as a kid that was so funny
he's like what he [ __ ] it up he's like
what are the chances of a guy like you
and a girl like me right making it and
she's like one in a million right and
he's like you're saying there's a chance
should you remember that verbatim bro
it's like one of my favorites Zach is
and my brother the only two people I
know they speak in sound bites they're
like bumblebee they just know movie
lines completely it's pretty amazing
it's a talent it is you have a you have
incredible memories Zach thank you did
you know that about yourself
um I see I was never great in school
with my memory but like the [ __ ] I care
about I I see yeah I see good for you
man thank you memories so closely
related to intelligence
new membership you have the keys to the
universe well just call me Albert
Einstein Fair will call you that
claimed that the liver King is
hormonally improved by science the
question has always been do you take
steroids do you take Peds the answer to
that is no I've always told the truth I
still tell the truth this is funny
people write in DMS right and they're
like they tell me what I'm taking right
and then here's the here's something
else I was just joking around I'd like
to get your opinion on this you know I
thought
so again for the record I've never taken
steroids really I'm thinking about doing
it yeah ancestral 10 and 10 is have a
little [ __ ] fun right and I'm like
you know what if you've built this
biological resilience I always say have
a little poison I I'll drink I'll do
mushrooms I'll do [ __ ] like every
Saturday and buy them like you know what
I'm healthy the [ __ ] you just say he
does mushrooms every Saturday
wait steroids isn't Fun you don't do
that to like have a good time on the
weekend bro I love how he's easy to get
you into it he's like okay maybe I'll
try steroids because y'all I heard
they're really fun because you kind of
like a good vibe I don't think steroids
like are not good it makes you like rage
shrinks your balls while Gooch's opinion
may not be the most fun [ __ ] up with
your gooch
if I want to do a cycle I'm gonna do a
cycle and how much you want to bet I
turn into the incredible [ __ ] hole
you're gonna be terrible I want to be
like this okay you you think this guy's
on steroids right this is the guy who's
on steroids it's like if somebody has
let's say 700 you know testosterone
pre-testosterone and and if they're
taking steroids and they want to get up
to 1400 or 1500 or whatever it is guess
what you can do the same thing with the
nine ancestral tenants and if you do the
nine ancestral tenants and you're living
this way over this amount of decades you
know you're going to be able to produce
your highest most dominant form so I
think when people
oh this is the guy okay this is the guy
that's coming on the show to debate Dr
IDs
and apparently he's in business with
liver King on these supplements
carnivore MD so I'm really [ __ ]
curious
this guy based a lot of his identity
around the same thing the carnivore the
meat diet and so when his guy liver King
comes out as a total fraud like a total
[ __ ] charlatan fraud in the highest
possible way
uh I wonder how that's going to change
his worldview you know what I mean yeah
not not at all I know the answer but be
someone with your with your physique uh
they just they look at it and they think
there's something going on here there's
gear there's steroids there's
performance enhancing drugs talk to us
about you know whether you use
performance enhancing drugs or steroids
or anything to get this physique
listen I love this question I've been
getting this question since high school
and it's done more to lift the liver
King Brandon message than any other
question I'm sure it has you asking it
now continues to do the same dude I feel
like him saying that
he is actually in some kind of legal
Jeopardy here he literally says there is
nothing that has helped this brand more
than me lying about being natural
like that's so incriminating
you know
and bro you you and for you to come into
our studio and smelling like [ __ ] like
like you didn't need to even do that
that was all a fraud man
take a shower
[Music]
why are you always lying oh my God
stop [ __ ] lying take a shower bro the
ax up man I say he does shower
and he just sprayed some like fart spray
on him before he came in because there's
no human that can smell that bad
I was lucky I didn't I wasn't here I
didn't I didn't get a whiff me too yeah
but it lingered I heard I think it's
possible frankly because this guy is so
dedicated to this character and it's all
a fraud
that he doesn't shower for a few days
leading up to podcasts and stuff this is
all a farce which is I guess his
dedication is impressive but I actually
think he might be in a bit of trouble
here let's see the short answer is no I
don't touch the stuff but here's the
deal isn't it just [ __ ] up that a
muscular lean man has to justify his
level of Fitness but a fat lazy
metabolically deranged or a skinny
fragile osteopathically deranged they
don't have to justify their lack of
Fitness oh the stupid [ __ ] idiot bro
that's such a dumb thing to say
see I'm unleashing a liver now
he lied to me yeah he came stunk up our
studio and lied to my face
yeah I feel bad for his kids too [ __ ]
what are they gonna do man
uh first of all please don't speak of
his kids in this context
yeah yeah I didn't I didn't say anything
I literally didn't say anything I
wouldn't
liver kids
why don't fat people have to justify
their [ __ ] fat
that's that's real easy to get fat and
we know how that works
well every King you're you're on
steroids you're on Peds you know and and
uh and so it's like okay you know we had
a lot of fun with that you know and and
then we we had a doctor come on we made
a video if you ever Google uh liver
King's blood work we had a legitimate
doctor come on we did like a blood work
reveal that was fun um but then the
accusations never stopped so I'm like
okay well I assume I was talking to
someone one of your guys and I was like
yeah he's not serious right like people
are looking he's like no he's not and I
know I think I'd heard Rogan say you
were on steroids everybody yeah
everybody now obviously it would not be
very ancestrally consistent to be using
synthetic lab synthesized drugs to
achieve the physique you then by the way
just to give this guy a shout out
I'm gonna go back to the beginning
that's when he mentions us right as the
top podcast in the world yeah we gotta
we gotta give love to more plates more
dates police emails blood test results
and a full steroid cycle breakdown
that's what we're going to be getting
into in this video and it is shocking to
say the least before we do though it
only feels fitting so go back to the
beginning around four minutes oh four
minutes yeah
yeah here it is check this out check out
this [ __ ] wait
didn't we already watched that part yeah
we watched it he said it no he no no no
there's a different part where he said
it's right at the beginning yeah yeah it
very much feels like a story that has
come full circle for us on this channel
and do what the Justice it deserves by
flushing it out from inception when I
first noticed the liver King he had one
percent of the following he does now
across all platforms if that and within
a year he has managed to build a fan
base of millions of followers and has
been on several of the biggest podcasts
that's respect and that
it's all about respect
listen more planes more dates
you come to me and you kiss the ring and
that is all I can ask
[Music]
and now let's talk about this stinky
[ __ ]
who makes people eat raw bold testicles
for no [ __ ] reason
it's absolutely [ __ ] absurd
[Music]
now I'm gonna I'm gonna you know what I
should do I should no I'm not gonna make
that joke not even gonna
nice try keemstar watching in the dark
flipping your toes I'm not even gonna
say it
Kim started screaming at the TV say it
nope
maybe I need a I need a jewel pod yeah
he might be saying that actually though
um
so here's he talks about basically
a lot about liver King's background and
all this but here is one part that I
really wanted to look at
so here's one of the leaked emails he
got by the way I love this subject is
confidentiality
and this was an email he sent right when
he started the brand the liver King yeah
it was around the same time he actually
so this was before his big catapult to
fame and before I hit this this lie
about being natural it almost is like he
started to believe it hmm
it's like yeah I am natural
even though he's injecting every day
twelve thousand dollars worth a month
I can't believe that delusion is a
powerful thing you know like George
Costanza once said it's not a lie if you
believe it right
so let me read this this is good
uh so stoked thank you what's a good day
and time for you to have our
consultation I live in the Republic of
Texas that's so cringe dude
Yeehaw I'm out here in the Republic of
Texas Houston that's right
we down here in Texas believe in liver
steers and lots of steroids
never talk about my wife in this context
liver you can have normal sex with your
wife now
if you get off the steroids
imagine all the positions you can try oh
maybe take a shower then she'll actually
want to sleep with you again
the Republic of Texas you mean the state
of Texas you [ __ ] idiot
stupid ass
until it gets hot in Texas
I live in the Republic of Texas I
believe that's 12 hours behind you this
is an absolute priority for me so I will
cancel almost any planned events to make
this happen with you my preferred times
are 7 A.M 8 A.M 9 A.M on Wednesday see
uh central time but could easily do six
or seven almost that she is so [ __ ]
into this
look at all this [ __ ] please check my
mail on that math on that since that's
outside of your regular hours I'm happy
to compensate for the trouble so let's
dig in
as it relates to my goals I'm the face
of several Brands including ancestral
supplements
it's incredible he's writing this all
out
like holy smokes
[Music]
and I've just this [ __ ] yelled
sub Primal at me you're on steroids
[ __ ] this is all natural [ __ ]
you think he has this Hyperbaric in that
email it says it yo
by the way thank you Bella Simmons she
says most of us Texans aren't that
embarrassing oh you're in Texas we love
we love our Texan fans shout out bill I
believe she donated uh over 50 Subs
before we even went live yeah oh that
was so cool I love her
she's our oil Baron our Texas oil Bearer
yeah Republican
public of Texas
I live in the independent country of
Texas
I live in The Sovereign Nation of Texas
as it relates to my goals I'm gonna face
several Brands including ancestral
supplements and I've just hired a team
to build the liver King brand with the
goal of 1 million followers by Marsh I
gotta say the team he hired the work he
did
to increase the brand awareness is
pretty incredible in terms of marketing
genius yeah genius
but you have to you have to consider the
real world ramifications right like
it's not a good foundation to build your
brand on this insane uh lie about health
you know I'm putting ridiculous
resources into making this happen
including hosting a video guy that will
be living at my guest house and a film
crew that would be filming seven days a
month stated I have to stay in great
[ __ ] shape year round
maybe take one
that was happening I'm moving this
because I'm trying to mute myself so I
can't hear the keyboard and I hit the x
button so I apologize as you were Dan is
just so disappointed
cigarettes right now he is looking like
that uh
Ben Affleck me
so he says to stay in great [ __ ]
shape year round maybe take one to two
months off per year what you taking time
off you never said anything about that
the hell here's a clip of where I'm at
currently
I've been working out for 35 years I
know how to eat train rest and recover I
even have a hard shell hyperbaric
chamber at my house let's go roll over
make some space for Jay Leno
this man could take a burn like no one
else just hop in that but that [ __ ]
yo
why the [ __ ] does he have a hyperbaric
chamber what does that do for recovery
what's the science there
love that for him though
probably does something with the muscles
after you worked out or something
something dumb it's got to be something
dumb right you're probably training like
Vegeta in there like nine times gravity
or something you think so because it
helps block the action of harmful
bacteria and strengthens the body's
immune system bacteria well he's eating
a lot of raw meat yeah he needs the help
his body's on the verb so like melt that
all off dude his body's on the verge at
any given moment they're like please bro
eat an orange we're about to have scurvy
it's just crazy the amount of [ __ ] you
money he has
like where'd he get it and this is
before him like his business went
absolutely nuts right
but do you guys believe 100 ml per year
I think that's a marketing too it's a
marketing thing right yeah it has to be
yeah well everything he said was a lie I
think like I mean the fact that he said
here he came here on a private jet paid
for us by by us you know as
he's setting up a foundation of lies
before he even got here yeah I feel so
betrayed dude I've been taking my 52
blood Vitality supplements my bone and
Marrow my uh beef liver every single
those are just sugar pills it was all
just a lie
well at least she didn't pay for it
that's true
[Music]
yep anyway
the the confusing thing is though is
that he says they do 100 million in
Revenue but he is clearly
extraordinarily wealthy
and so
it begs the question which is on all of
our minds is where do you get the money
from before this
um
now if he's doing a hundred million it's
it's very unlikely probably but I don't
know it's possible listen he's obviously
doing a lot of business
and there's a lot of people that really
do respect liver King and actually
believe that he was natural
I mean let's look on Tick Tock how many
[ __ ] out here talking about
Ethan hates exercise
just got done eating some Seer testicles
Tech Reg
baby
he just ate steer testes
this guy's such a [ __ ] linetic
so anyway he's got his hyperbaric
chamber how much is a hyperbaric chamber
cost
is that on Amazon
he's called it a horror he called it a
hard shell hyperbaric chamber that
sounds a big deal four thousand to
twenty thousand is what I'm saying oh
that's not bad yeah
or maybe I should invest
just for the jokes of it I mean they go
up though I mean they actually go up
even more than I'm seeing Oh that's a
four person for eighty thousand yo it's
a party in there we're gonna get one for
the office
that's awesome so if next time Jay Leno
crashes and he's got guests in the car
they can all hop in that [ __ ] and have
a party
love that for him we're bound to have at
least one Gatsby injury
you know we could use that well yeah
we'll just get them in the chamber yep
it's gonna be me he says but I've
reached my mid-40s and it's getting
harder and the back fat [ __ ] kills me
he's serious what a vain little [ __ ]
back fat
to support these exhaustive efforts I've
recently started taking omnitrope
the 5.8 milligram vials from Empower
Pharmacy
11 000 USD per month for my new dose
which is four vials per week
18 vials per month
I don't know if this [ __ ] is grossly
underdosed or what but I have been
taking two vials per week
and my igf-1 is only at 139.
my doctor told me I could double it in
an effort to get to the upper 200s lower
300s
she thinks okay you're not talking about
his wife who's a dentist is he
she thinks I could be his wife's not a
dentist right like that's got to be a
lie you never talk about my wife in this
context like she's a dentist I don't
know
I know a great dentist
who
thank you
she thinks I could be a hyper
non-responder
I wonder if taking a [ __ ] load of other
peptides could be confounding the
results and possibly interfering with
efficacy for instance here's what I'm
currently taking so he's saying yo dude
I'm taking a shitload of steroids and
it's not getting where I need to be
something's off
meat [ __ ] ain't working man juice me up
he's he's literally asking about
steroids is he writing to like a steroid
specialist I mean you know that seems to
be
the main concern here he's he says he's
good at exercising and all that
so here's all the [ __ ] he's on
and we actually did a breakdown here
because I was I wanted to know like okay
was it what is the classification of
each of these what is their legal status
and what is each one so let's go through
this list one by one and I think this
can be really interesting again remember
this man said he was natural
and he's on seven different [ __ ]
steroids why the [ __ ] you lying why you
always lying so again
[Music]
recently I lost my eyesight the hell
this person said Elite she says I lost
my eyesight my health my mom and my
house
where are you right now
[ __ ]
she got nothing left but she's like in a
Starbucks or something listen to
Industry podcast love that
I'm saying
that's uh horrible
that is horrible yeah
sorry about that
uh Cassidy happy birthday to your sister
Lauren 24.
liver Queen credentials so do we know
that she has a DDS
to
um an interview she did she does have
her DDS degree she said that yes without
a public knowledge yes
this public knowledge
it
I mean in terms of this interview
no she just said it yeah we're still
looking we're a registered doctor I have
not seen it look up her credential
claims yes people
um have found her credentials online I I
know there's a like a dentist
um
website yeah for anyone down there
fulfilled it yeah okay good for her
dentists can prescribe medicine I don't
know if they can prescribe steroids
maybe they can
all right well we'll find out that all
these aren't even legal in the first
place
oh so so yeah so let's get into this and
again it's not that he's taking steroids
right that's not shocking it's the
amount is the amount this guy could kill
a [ __ ] rhinoceros with the amount of
storage he's taken
oh my God
all right so the first one we've got
here is igf he's been taking this for a
year
igf is a drug used to treat children
with insulin-like growth factor is what
it sounds like uh what it's is acronym
for
a deficiency this deficiency can result
in symptoms like being extremely short
or metabolic disorders such as decreased
bone density or insulin resistance it's
only legal if you have a prescription so
this drug is used with children who are
suffering from a deficiency that makes
them short
and this [ __ ] is like I'm on
this now he's like I'm basically he's
very short so maybe he thought that
would make him taller yeah it doesn't
work with adults the same not at all
before adolescence like at a certain age
it does help but a lot of times
sometimes it causes the kids to have
like super straight legs is what I've
seen personally but like uh yeah it
shoots them up almost like instantly
like taller what does it do in an adult
in an adult I know it doesn't it won't
get an adult taller uh to my knowledge
but uh I'll look it up
no wonder he's screaming Primal all the
time this man is he's he's trying to
channel his rage
so he's on igf uh for a year
it is oh there's more info here about
wait
the next one is C J C with IMAP this is
not sold to the general public or even a
tent intended for human use
it's a synthetic growth hormone
that has been researched for hormone
deficiency Sleep Quality and anti-aging
he's been on that for a year it's not
even intended for human use my friends
he's on that experimental [ __ ] just like
our ancestors used to do you know you
know yeah
that's Primal As It Gets
[Music]
the previous one for adults could be
used to increase other anabolic steroids
the efficiency of them to it the
previous one we were talking about igf
yeah it could help with adults with if
they're using other steroids as well
yeah
Synergy it has good Synergy with other
steroids
that's awesome
uh the third one he's on
this guy's such a fraud Primal dude
my body's more natural than yours
talking about fat people and [ __ ]
hell no I'm not eating that bold
testicles I regret eating that liver I
was under fraudulent pretense
third one IBU IBU taymorin been on it
for two months
still an investigational new drug
it has not even been approved to be
marketed for the consumption of humans
in the United States this [ __ ]
is just out there in the outer spaces of
steroid consumption
it's an exploratory drug
that has not been approved for human
consumption
omnitrope
he's been taken for six weeks
this is a human growth hormone
which you can get with a prescription
but what do you what do they prescribe
that for like what's a legit condition
to take human growth hormone I'm growing
my hair low energy uh is one low energy
a lot of times what I can get I can get
that for low energy most doctors they'll
just write off I mean you got to say
that you know it's hard for you to wake
up in the morning you can't do this
can't do that what
hell no that can't be true uh yeah
I'm looking it up
human growth hormone for if you're low
energy doesn't that [ __ ] up your body
I'll make sure the description medicine
that contains human growth hormone is
used to treat children with growth
failure due to growth hormone deficiency
crater Willy syndrome
small for gastro
gastrointational age Turner syndrome
idiopathic short stature and adults with
either adult onset or childhood onset
ghd I don't know what the [ __ ] doctor
you go to bro
I mean dude that's that's part of it
overall I mean you there's you know it
helps with muscles as well if you're
having like muscle problems your bone
density
but yeah I've heard people just going
saying that uh I don't know if that's
what they exactly told the doctor just
that I need energy but uh you know that
their bones hurt it's hard for them to
move stuff like that
uh
uh
okay I've fallen and I can't get up
benefits and yeah I mean
this [ __ ] is crazy everybody we've seen
it how it affected Joe Rogan it makes
him all bloated it makes your head big
makes you all red it's [ __ ] crazy
whatever happened to Coffee Red Bull
so he's on that the next one is test
cyp
R he's been on that
every week
testosterone supplement also requires a
prescription
he's on Deca
every week
Deca is an androgen an anabolic steroid
medicine
which is used primarily in the treatment
of
enemies and wasting syndromes as well as
osteoporosis and menopausal women so
there it is he's he's in Good Company
you know there's nothing more Primal
than a woman in menopause well that's
true but I guess is someone who's
obsessed with masculinity
he actually has more common with the uh
Jim rummy haul that he does with people
at the gym
you know medically speaking
Chet is saying that I was thinking of
trt not uh HGH but
what is trt trt I I guess is what I was
describing let's say trt
testosterone replacement therapy yeah
j-rh okay okay yeah yeah trt that's if
you get old and [ __ ] you get your
hormones Get Low they give you some of
that yeah that's not human growth
hormone bro that shit's crazy to take
yeah I mean it does help with those
things but yeah I guess that's not the
primary reason I guess it has to be a so
you still think you're talking about
human growth hormone or trt
I'm not I think I maybe I'll talk about
trt but HGH does help with energy and it
does help with the bones as well
um but yeah okay I mean meth helps with
energy but I don't know if I would
prescribe it for that yeah
[Music]
um
then what's this Deca [ __ ] deca
yeah that's the one where the
osteoporosis and menopause and then he's
on Winstrol
just started this one but taking it for
three weeks exciting anabolic steroids
legally prescribed for treating
hereditary
angiodoma severe swelling
what the [ __ ] this guy's on so much [ __ ]
I can't imagine a more complex cocktail
of steroids and experimental drugs is
crazy so in summary Two drugs that are
flat out not even approved for human
consumption
one growth hormone that is legal for a
prescription with people like severe
diseases
two anabolic steroids that are legal
with just uh prescriptions
and testosterone supplement which are
legal prescription
and one growth supplement meant for sick
children
and two testicles uncooked
uh your mic was muted I think oh and two
testicles that aren't cooked uncooked
mm-hmm
so there you have it and he said he's
spending thirteen thousand dollars a
month man
foreign
soon but let's get some sound bites
let's see what uh more bars more dates
more plates more dates has to say about
it this guy's a you know he knows what
he knows what he's talking about at the
start of the video I mentioned how there
was some information that came across my
desk that was shocking to say the least
this set of redacted emails shows what
appears to be liver King corresponding
with a bodybuilding coach
so I was shocked but also kind of not
shocked at the same time like I felt
like it was just a matter of time before
something like this came out in some
capacity but obviously you know it was
still surprising to see the name on the
piece of paper and just the detail that
he went into in these emails so let's
get into it um and as far as I know the
redactions included like personal
information that was irrelevant to Peds
and blood test results it was just like
payment information phone numbers
personal information Etc
um and we'll get into the blood work
after I just want to go through all the
emails fully before we that is actually
yeah incidentally
someone named chat pointed out all the
steroids he's taking will destroy liver
King's liver
I mean his internal organs are screaming
for help dude
the liver
you know cleans your blood right it gets
rid of toxins and this man is
no wonder he needs it you know he eats
as much liver as he can to help his own
it's something like that I think if if
this man was caught in like a let's say
he was surround uh
he was stranded in the jungle in a line
ate him or something you know I think
that line would drop [ __ ] dead I
think it would die on the front oh yeah
the hell is this me
it's like the puffer fish you know you
got to prepare it right to get all rid
of the little poisons
the puffer fish right the one that turns
into a circle are you [ __ ] serious
how did you do that so fast the goat how
did you hit the puffer fish so
literally and I've never said puffer
fish like ever on this show
I have everything man I was shocked that
one which got me you got me on that one
okay wow thank you yeah I mean that was
fast man upper [ __ ] okay
Magellan back there The Wizard of Oz he
opened the blood test results because it
gives a lot of context that then makes
sense of the blood work thereafter so
this is the first email June 29th 2021
which is notable that this is actually
almost two months before we started
posting as liver King on social media
and yet he seemingly filled out this
contact form identifying himself as
Brian Johnson liver King in Brackets
with an official email liver K and
ancestralsupplements.com like this is
very much his brand domain that he is
emailing through in His official email
address presumably from his company
email address so no attempt at trying to
claim natural or anything like very very
transparent in this email about what he
needs to get out of this what his goals
are over the next year and also
identifying himself literally yeah
whatever
um I think what happened to liver is
that he got way too big you know I don't
think he ever expected it becomes such a
meme becomes so big that
he really set himself up for failure in
a way he got so [ __ ] big and the lie
was so ridiculous
every King shares his daily schedule
this I'm curious about walking in the
park Etc so this is pretty interesting
wake up at 6am work out at 7 A.M and 1
p.m I always train fasted if I'm not
going to my Ranch I don't leave my
compound I live on 15 Acres on the lake
and have everyone come to me okay Flex
he's just a he's just a fitness coach
bro you don't need to you don't need a
stunt on him
I'm in the Republic of Texas I own half
the state
don't ask how
branch is 500 Acres of paradise I don't
go out to eat I don't go bowling I don't
go to the movies bowling who [ __ ]
tests
bully that's not like a common uh hob
activity
not that common to bring it up like that
a roll of 300. I don't bowl God damn it
out here in the Republic of Texas
this is my routine 6 a.m wake up walk to
the lake Barefoot Sun gaze and have
morning coffee why are you so
embarrassing dude this is just a fitness
coach she doesn't need to know you walk
around barefoot
why are you trying to impress him so
insecure God touch the Earth with your
feet man okay you know what I mean like
this guy doesn't give a [ __ ]
review the books for my companies 7 A.M
workout number one I follow West Side
conjugate and customize the program as
needed I take the first dose of
omnitrope right before this workout I
love that he goes I wake up 6 a.m my
feet touch the Earth I'm one with the
Earth 7 A.M I shoot myself up with
experimental serum
yeah
that is illegal in most Western
countries
ah yes the natural way
at 9 00 a.m I inject a child I inject
medicine for children with stunted
growth into my testicles
then I exercise and eat 10 eggs
I am eat meal one 45 gram protein shake
with cold mineral water 60 grams
dextrose 100 grams whole Greek yogurt 30
grams maple syrup four farm fresh eggs 5
grams creatine 10 grams collagen 30
grams almond butter 20 grams ghee 5
grams Redmond salt two ounces of red
meat so it's kind of interesting to eat
salt you just eats salt
somebody is that what that means what's
Redmond salt
is he dropping a brand name of salt he's
trying to plug wait I gotta know is he
just eating salt
undefined natural salt that is a brand
of salt how much does five grams of salt
like
do you put it on your food or
do you just eat salt like a [ __ ]
horse
this man has this Salt Lick
I love by the way how he goes I eat all
this stuff and only two ounces of red
meat because you know I'm trying to be
conscious we don't eat a lot of red meat
save the environment five grams of salt
is equivalent to one teaspoon
you think he just teaspoons the salt
down he's probably just like seasoning
his food with it and he let the doctor
know okay
I like to imagine he just eats it
straight up me too and it says it has
nutritional benefits I mean I'm not
believing that but yes Redmond salt
don't do [ __ ] I guarantee salt is salt
it's one of those things like water salt
is salt
she saw pink salt Himalayan salt salt
it makes the the carcass taste
yes it enhances flavor
there's two there's two types of salt
chunky salt and fine salt
is it to hold the water in his body
that's what salt does bro yeah I'm
saying is that is that why he's doing it
so he could keep some of his his
buffness
there is some effect of like I I don't
maybe yeah maybe surprised he doesn't
sprinkle it in the HGH you know a little
extra flavor yeah a little salt in the
syringe yeah there you go man
that'll wake you up in the morning
salt is not just salt sorry guys I knew
this was gonna happen
okay water is not just water I guess
that's true
salt is salt though sorry guys there's
flaky salt yeah there's different like
textures and sizes but there's no salt
that's like better for you that's some
dumb [ __ ]
sorry to offend you all but
and I love salt I'm a salt I'm a salt
sommelier okay well what what's the uh
the sea in Israel what is it the uh Dead
Sea the Dead Sea just salt it's got a
lot of salt
there's iodized salt and non-iodized
salt yeah okay
not quite sure what that means but yeah
that's true there are those two
anyway whatever next thing because I
wonder some of the stuff I've never seen
him have like 60 grams of dextrose
powder never seen that before him
supplementing with creatine is really
interesting given how much red meat he
eats 10 grams of collagen powder
presumably
um interesting stuff 9 15 to 1 p.m
meetings and phone calls with the
occasional nap from 12 to 1. 1 30 p.m
what a [ __ ] dude
making little snoozes in the middle of
the day liver King
I bet your ass he ain't sleeping on that
wooden bed
he got one of those nice cushy beds with
like horse hair and [ __ ] that cost like
fifty thousand dollars you know he ain't
liver King you ain't sleeping on no
board bed I don't believe that [ __ ] for
a second anymore your whole Life's a lot
dude
he probably has stuffed animals little
uh
you know My Little Pony stuffed animals
he likes the pink one
I think it's all sweet and cute in his
bathrobe
jrhnd cuddles up for a little nap he has
a little cap a little sleepy cap of
course with hair like that
we love that for him
Olympic lifting skills and metcon I take
the second dose of omnitrope right
before this workout 2 30 p.m eat meal
too 45 gram protein shake with cold
mineral water 60 grams of dextrose again
100 grams whole Greek yogurt 60 grams
maple syrup four farm fresh eggs five
grams creatine 10 grams collagen 30
grams almond butter 20 grams of ghee 5
grams of Redmond salt two to four ounces
of Raw Liver 30 grams of raw bone marrow
three to four Thirty meetings and phone
calls 4 30 eat meal number three 12
ounce of full fat red meat for example
ribeye ground wagyu or short ribs and
100 to 200 grams sweet potatoes 5 30 to
6 30 phone calls emails meetings 6 30 to
7 walking with wife seven to seven
thirty that's nice he makes 30 minutes
to walk with his wife
you know
I like that for him it's sweet connects
with the Earth is he barefoot hold on
baby hold on I gotta Jam hold on baby I
gotta get some of this experimental
[ __ ]
knock it over my wife house coarse
hormones into my
gooch
hold on baby
emails 7 30 to 8 30. spend time with the
boys usually go to the theater room to
watch a Marvel movie or play the boys
get one hour of day from him but not
bowling no bowling no bowling no bowling
he goes the boys I get one hour boys
it's Dad time I can imagine that 7 30
it's Dad time he just said it's like an
alarm clock in there all right we got
one hour let's go to the let's go watch
oh then they watch movies let's go watch
movies that's one hour how you gonna
watch a Marvel yeah he said they get a
third of a Marvel movie
all right nice to see you today boys and
and first
games 8 30 p.m I take the third dose of
omni Trope wait 30 and by the way like
each dose he's taking essentially is
3.33 international units presumably per
shot wait 30 minutes after the Omni
Trope have a 30 gram protein shake and
two ounces of red meat and get ready for
bed at 9pm dead time how many hours of
sleep do you get every day my sleep is
not great I go to sleep no problem but
wake up a lot from 2 A.M to 6 a.m this
is why I stay in bed nine to ten hours a
night so that I can usually get around
eight hours of legit sleep
maybe uh not on the board he doesn't
sleep on a board right that's such
that's total [ __ ] [ __ ] he's
probably waking up from the chest pains
yeah yeah he's probably on all he's
probably on one of those um
what's those machines that help you
breathe oxygen machine uh no it's like
if you're a lot of oh cpaps like for
snoring yeah yeah some people they need
like a full mask because they can die in
their sleep yeah CPAP love that
I love that so this is really
interesting to me because the guy you
know preaches sleep hygiene dialed in
sleep and you would think is like the
you know representation of Pinnacle of
Lifestyle behavioral Etc modifications
to have this person I'm not surprised he
didn't sleep great he demand's on like
seven steroids that's gonna [ __ ] up your
your vibes your body Vibes perfectly
dialed in but yet he is waking up a lot
two to six a.m having issues sleeping he
stays into 10 hours a night to get eight
hours of legit sleep and we'll get into
his blood work later why I think that to
be partially the case who knows if it's
from lying on this is super interesting
I the level of detail that we have into
this man's life is
so [ __ ] interesting this this is such
a compromising leak like we got the
whole meal it wasn't just the steroids
it wasn't just the routine we got the
whole
meal
here's the blood results
of that
check this out
James Dixon Ethan I'm not one to follow
drama I just want to know what your
current opinion of Andrew Tate
where do you currently stand just
thought I'd ask directly
I don't think my opinions of him has
changed why would it
did something happen
I don't think so Andrew Tate I mean
what do you what do you want to know
that I haven't said a million times
about the guy
uh my neck it doesn't exist I don't know
what to say
that email now moving on to the August
16th email GH and igf-1 PMP is in the
lobby so maybe let's take his call and
then we'll continue the let's go the
clips yeah so I I asked um
our our favorite lawyer
we love so well
he is uh the man
he is the man responsible David
for releasing all the villains back into
Gotham
but he demanded believes in in the legal
system and freedom and representation
you know what I mean and there he is
David from PNP
America's favorite attorney
hey how's it going how are you you're
all suited up you got court today
yeah I was at court this morning and uh
you know I haven't posting anything on
my Tick Tock for a long time and uh it's
crazy yesterday I just posted started
posting stories I I'm making an effort
to make a comeback and uh yeah people
are really liking it and telling me I
should you know who cares if I don't
have a client next to me just do some
talking so that's what I'm gonna do yeah
don't go don't call it a comeback you've
been here for years
yeah no but I mean like you know with
with putting out content
David there's an empty spot on the wall
did you get this barred in some spot or
what happened no no I took uh I take my
Awards down you know I don't like uh
having my Awards uh oh you took the
award down because you you're are you
being bashful
uh yeah yeah you can say that well come
on let's see the award David don't be
shy
no it's not a big deal okay okay okay
all right
how'd you do in court this morning you
crush it
absolutely yeah that's absolutely yeah
we uh I posted the video with the client
I I didn't think the client was going to
be willing because it's a very serious
case he was falsely accused of sexual
battery
um and it just really turned his life
upside down and I know this type of
stuff happens every day and it's
despicable but uh you know people are
truly falsely accused of that as well
and when that happens that's also really
bad
you you posted a new video with him is
it on tick tock yeah
probably like 30 minutes oh yes yeah
he's so you're saying this you're saying
this man is innocent
innocent as [ __ ] okay
with my great client uh he was falsely
accused of a sexual battery okay this is
a very serious case it's a very serious
allegation okay it's a horrible thing to
do
a horrible thing to commit sexual crimes
however it's extremely horrible to
falsely accuse an innocent person of
that so my client here was facing
lifetime registration as a sex offender
and and that's much worse than any jail
time he was facing and I'm pleased to
announce that today the case was
dismissed all right we came to court for
the first time about a month ago my
client exercises constitutional right to
speedy trial we did not get any
continuances we went we wanted to go
straight to trial trial was about to
start with the prosecutors today dropped
the case how do you feel
muffle his voice just to just to keep
him anonymous because I you know I I
don't want any trouble uh in the future
you can all see the comments people are
saying like oh he's guilty for sure he's
guilty for sure there's no way he's
guilty like trust me I've got like crazy
witness statements on this case like we
did a crazy investigation here so I just
wanted to keep him safe do you do you
put the mask on him to keep his
anamenity is that your yeah suggestion
yeah and those that the glasses too
those are mine
yeah Olivia she thinks that he's
innocent she could tell from looking at
him I said his face you can tell when
you like really look at it he looks his
forehead looks innocent as [ __ ]
yeah no he's a really good guy okay
let's see let's see what let's see what
he says that threw me off I'm not gonna
lie go straight to the trial trial was
about to start with the prosecutors
today
I don't think he will help he sounds
more like a Batman villain than ever
these are still great
with it hey freed Bane
felt almost as great as okay I'm not
gonna go there yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's right
[Music]
I would recommend him as number one I
know a lot of our children yes
[Music]
that's an endorsement
all right let's go yeah that one wasn't
as funny and I'll tell you why it's
because you you didn't outline what he
was accused of in great detail that's my
favorite part
yeah I mean I could do that now for you
guys I love that
so it was uh it was this girl that
worked for him
and she worked there a little bit more
than a month or so
uh and
uh
she you know something happened that she
quit that was very irresponsible for her
and
um it was about like a boy okay and she
ditched work to go hang out with this
guy didn't want her mom to know and
meanwhile the things that she's accusing
my client of happened to her friend like
actually happened to her friend like you
know former boss uh made sexual advances
towards her every time she went to work
sexual advances uh come talk to me alone
in my room and well you know we can have
a relationship oh I can buy you an
apartment I can do this and that like
all these creepy things and uh comments
on her breasts and stuff like that and
you know we we found a witness who's you
know her friend who said no look like
what she did I like I gotta come clean
to you she copy and pasted all the
horrible things that really did happen
to me and it's really bad when it
happens I suffered through it and I
can't believe that she just you know
because she was two and embarrassed to
tell her mom why she really like left
work and was irresponsible and quit the
job uh you know she she just told her
mom a lie the mom went and got a lawyer
and told her to go to the police took
her to the police and it all spiraled
and and I've hung out with her many
times since then and and every time she
just tells me you know I kind of wish I
never said that to my mom and and oh she
even walked it back we worked there
the the accuser walked it back
yeah well walked it back to her friends
but you know when it came to the police
and everything she's like you know what
I might as well make money because you
made money when you did this you you
know what I mean so oh she was gonna go
through it she wanted to get paid off
yeah but paid off by who isn't it
illegal isn't it like a punitive thing
not a civil lawsuit or was it
well this was criminal yeah from a civil
case also hmm
good for you man
let's no this was really bad man like is
she gonna get is she is she on the line
now if when you lie about something like
that
technically yes but I told the
prosecutor look this case is closing but
you got to start another one against her
this is I it's despicable you can't let
her go unpunished for this because she's
gonna think it's okay like and I can
just do this and get away with it that's
not right it could have been me it could
have been you it could have been any one
of your friends this is you know you
guys prosecute people for such Petty
things this is in my opinion
this is a really bad this is like this
is felony level yeah what she did is
there any chance that your client there
has
drove under the influence of some drug
crashed into a police car got taken out
by the jaws of life or fight the police
or anything like that okay dang that's
those are my favorite
I know me too but he's actually a good
guy and I don't like representing actual
innocent people it's it's so much
pressure for me because it's like
hold on hold on back up back up say that
again say that from the beginning I I
don't know if I misheard you
it's really difficult representing
people people who are totally innocent
wow but falsely accused can I ask
something is this the first time you've
used the filter the
The Voice filters yeah
yeah so so so
you're saying actually innocent victims
are the hardest to defend huh
yeah
look there's legally that there are
people who who are not guilty okay
but that's different than if you're
actually innocent right guilty means
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
but oh what happened yeah you're back
you're you can be not guilty Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt but but he still
[ __ ] did it you know what I mean
like OJ this guy we're talking like when
you say yeah you when you say uh
innocent with like air quotes we're
talking like OJ innocent right
I in my opinion
OJ look OJ had a lot of a lot of
evidence man I'm telling you like the
hair look his hair on both dead bodies
like how did it get him something that I
heard
they found his hair on both dead bodies
I didn't even know that that's what I
was doing that's awesome that's when I
worked there I don't know if that piece
of evidence came out during trial I
don't know if they had DNA back then or
whatever but uh I mean if
that's pretty damning you know what I
mean that's awesome well I'm glad OG is
out there living his best life in
Florida golfing every day and talking
about politics sharing his thoughts on
stuff we should listen to him he's a
good man and he's innocent quote unquote
so the justice system works right
he was not guilty yeah he's not guilty
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly exactly
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt right he was
innocent as [ __ ] yeah he's innocent as
[ __ ] in other words
oh I love you Dave you're the best
all right so are you familiar with the
liver King controversy that we I wanted
to ask you about at all
um I've seen his videos in the past and
I have I've seen some stuff about yeah
I'm familiar with the controversy I I
don't know if I know everything but I've
definitely seen a good amount of content
in the last few days about it okay so
let me set this up for you in the best
way I can and then you can give me
your professional opinion on if he is in
some kind of legal Jeopardy okay
so liver King obviously owns this huge
supplement brand he sells supplements
and he isn't we watched a clip of him
saying verbatim one of the best things
for my brand has been this question of
are you on steroids he said nothing has
helped my brand grow more than people
ask me am I on steroids and the answer
of course is no I'm all natural
and he has talked over many times on
tick tock on lots of different shows
about how
these supplements and his lifestyle
uh enables him to have this physique and
he's not on steroids well it's come out
recently he's on an an incredible amount
of stairways suffering several different
steroids thirteen thousand dollars a
month you've got these leaked emails
where he's talking about his blood work
and he's talking about
uh all this stuff he lied about and so
my question is
if he's selling the supplement with the
promise
that it's more like an indirect promise
maybe if we're getting into the legal
aspect of it although I'm sure
a lawyer would do a deeper analysis
but um
what he has done is
is essentially lied outright provably
in an effort to sell his supplements is
this what do you think is this is this I
know morally it's [ __ ] up but legally
what do we think about this
it's illegal it's illegal I don't know
do you know what state he's in Texas the
Republic of Texas
okay The Sovereign Nation of Texas Texas
law but I know that uh I mean look he's
selling these things online right so
so if I'm in California which I am I I
could just buy his stuff online yes yes
uh
I can speak about at least California
law uh there are a couple laws at least
that he's violating
uh both criminal and civil
uh the criminal it's not that bad it's
just a misdemeanor like false
advertising not it's honestly not a big
deal but you could get them off on that
probably huh
hmm no he he could I mean depending on
what he's represented like like look
him saying that the fact that I'm all
natural was has been huge for my company
tells me that he's probably made
statements I I don't know you tell me
has he made statements that look like if
you take this product and you work out
like I do you're gonna look like me yes
I think that's provable probably
so I mean if we inject those facts that
he he's made representations that I'm
natural and like you just got to take my
product and this is do what I do as I
preach you know and this is this can be
your body he could potentially be guilty
of that uh because it's it's a false
advertisement uh but Paul Savage but
here's the thing even stronger than that
okay forget the criminal like they're
never going to come after for that
but what can happen is he can get sued
and it can even be a class action like a
really really big bad class action where
there's punitive damages on that stake
like I wouldn't be surprised if you can
go bankrupt over it sounds wow okay
that's really interesting and this is
why this is why okay
um
in California at least I'm sure Texas
and all these other states probably have
similar statutes here it's the consumers
legal remedies act all right and
even you don't need to in actual fraud
is not required and an actual intent to
fraud defraud is not even required even
if you just like negligently defrauded
people
all right if he just if he just like
knew what he was doing was deceptive or
it was like negligently deceptive
that he's guilty of that that's so
interesting yeah there's punitive
damages If he if he knew that it was
deceptive and just didn't care that's
recklessness that then at that point
then he's acted with conscious disregard
and and
there you go that is so yeah yeah it's
it struck me as something where I was
like this seems really bad for him to
have lied so blatantly about this and
and he frankly he grew too big he became
too successful and now I think he's
going to be in a lot of trouble
the email actually like I I read the
email it was with his like some guy he
wanted to coach him and he he says like
hey uh uh I'm taking this list of of
steroids I know like uh
um testosterone with one of them and I
don't know if that's illegal or not but
uh it's just like a laundry list at this
point and he he's wrote like eleven
thousand dollars a month in steroids and
like oh my God and and he's saying my
doctor says that this is okay but I want
to know from you if if uh you know what
you recommend and I'm just thinking like
What doctor would like allow him to do
this and was he even truly prescribed
this stuff like I don't that's my
question his wife is a dentist
what what I don't know if a dentist can
prescribe steroids like these maybe you
need Mouse to emulate yeah human growth
hormones a little weird for for uh but
he's super rich you know I'm sure he
finds someone out there in Texas to
[ __ ] shoot him up with horse
tranquilizer or whatever he takes
look I mean I've been to Mexico and you
can see there are these pharmacies
everywhere you can buy drugs that are
illegal in the U.S and they got signs
like like human growth hormone or
whatever steroids and then they also
sell like like
oxycodone and that's crazy but you know
you're just walking around and there's
like pharmacies like literally having a
list of all these things that are
illegal in the U.S and you just go and
you know buy them that's crazy where was
that
Mexico really do you remember this the
city that's crazy that's super dangerous
I've seen it in I have seen it in a
what's it called Rosarito really what's
the closest airport that's so [ __ ] up
the closest airport yeah how'd you get
there
uh I drove I mean you drove I am that's
crazy I wonder if you could get that
pass pack over the Border without any
problems
um well I mean I never try to smuggle
anything but I know like the two times
I've been in Mexico in the last few
years I don't think I'll search coming
back [ __ ] and do you know what that cost
was or or like do I have to no idea do I
need to say like a code word or they
just they it's there I can buy I mean
yeah you can buy it damn that's wild
do you remember the name of the pharmacy
or no they're everywhere I'm telling you
just walk around like it's like almost
every block like in the in the tourist
area they know that the tourists are
going to want this stuff that's crazy
man anyway walk around
that's crazy anyway thinking about going
to Mexico over this winter break coming
up
all right let's do it let's go let's go
would you get blasted with me down in
Mexico
David yeah hell yeah I would [ __ ] let's
go get let's let's go get some DUIs in
Mexico and crash into [ __ ] fight the
police and [ __ ]
all right I'm down you know we'll uh
nothing will happen to you even I'll be
totally fine yeah I'm sure you'll be
fine I have you back that sounds fun I'd
love to do that with you all right well
yeah that's interesting you know I it's
interesting to hear it's gonna be
fascinating to to see how this develops
because
seems pretty [ __ ] up but thanks for
the Insight David as always yeah no I
mean he and I feel bad because like I I
think he's been on your show I saw that
and seems like a nice guy but
um you know
you know it's unfortunate you know the
if a case can be made that people were
deceived on a great scale you know he he
could really be facing a huge class
action like huge yeah wow okay let's see
maybe liver King uh
you know someone said something funny he
might liver King might be having some
liver failure with the amount of
steroids he's on
I mean it doesn't look like that he
looks pretty healthy but I don't know
what would I know what's going on yeah
all right David you're the greatest man
keep letting those keep letting those
Crim I mean innocent people off okay
I will yeah I will thank you Ethan all
right thank you buddy you're the best
let's go David from PNP attorneys the
one and only
let's go America's favorite lawyer let's
go
let's go take care buddy see you in
Mexico
see you
love that man he's a gem Legend
I love him uh
what the [ __ ] is this
one of the ancestral tenants asleep by
the way it's the first thing it's the
first one yeah are you gonna get loaded
by suing yeah I want to prosecute it I'm
not ready I want money you've been
taking those pills yeah I'm not ripped
yet come on dude the first ancestral
tenant is sleep because it trumps
everything else it's the time when body
and brain detox recover rebuild and
restore here he is taking a nap
I sleep and I'm not ripped I want to sue
[Music]
yeah the wood planks is just a set this
is what his actual bed looks like and
it's sweet it's cute he feels comfy
there it's his comfort nap Place baby
sad
it's exact
baby wants baby wants
anyway so back to the video I wanted to
see the results of his blood work I'm
very interested in this because this
will tell us if he's healthy or not
check this out I did Omni insurance this
was my whole Theory right like on the
whole Joe Rogan fat man bad Joe Rogan
healthy
just because you got big muscles doesn't
mean you're healthy you know at all
these big weight lifters who like
like these Mr Olympians they are like
one day from their heart exploding they
are not healthy [ __ ] you okay sorry Joe
maybe I don't know as much as you about
it we're up one hour before the blood
test on August 4th I did nordie Trope
nordotropin one hour before the blood
test on August 11th but igf-1 is slowly
Rising too I'd love to get my igf-1 to
300. a quick interjection for a note on
the blood work analysis I ended up doing
it and it ended up being over an hour in
length I wanted it to be this succinct
concise cursory overview okay so
whatever bro he's gonna come out with a
second video okay that's fun that's fun
I'm actually look forward to that but
you know we're we've been on this for a
while and we got to do our influencer
products so let's just say
um that liver King is caught oh he
responded to very cryptically this was
posted what yesterday yeah this is the
only thing he's posted nothing today uh
so the uh first one was yesterday and
then the second one
um the picture in the other video was
posted this morning this
this was posted this morning yeah yes
yeah yeah stay tuned
and then the video below
okay so let's let's start with this one
this is right when people were talking
about it it's having for dinner today
but first I couldn't be more grateful to
know my fight my unite my purpose my
passion where to point my energy because
people are living a life of hurt hate
suffering struggle and there's a better
life to live and it can be achieved
through ancestral living I couldn't be
more grateful for some of the guys
sitting on the couch making reaction
video surfacing new information that's
gonna lead to some yeah so I thought it
was funny that he goes the guys on the
couch implying like uh these you know
these guys who just are like fatties
keyboard Warriors but the guy who made
this video about him is like
he lit liver King wrote him asking for
help years ago he's like a bodybuilding
expert so I don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about
I didn't say it I'm watching this video
some goddamn good discussions and so now
this is what Leonard King is having for
dinner I got lamb shanks I got a whole
Feast protein shake I got raw bone
marrow raw testicle raw liquor brother
Jig Is up just have a you know what I
mean just like have some Falafel or
something uh like I know you want to
have some barbecue [ __ ]
stay tuned and then here's the video
from this morning we sure wins to create
momentum to put each other into momentum
to create the winning mindset to create
the winning ecosystem here's my win so
many friends family and leaders have
been reaching out to me
sharing the love sharing their support
what and it feels good it feels good to
be loved it feels good to be supported
it feels good to have true Earnest
intentions at your back and now it's
prime time to launch into the day make
sure to start every day the same even
when it's cold even when it's overcast
even when it's snowing get the early
morning sun Through The Eyes on the face
on the skin get the Barefoot connected
anchored grounded into your primals grab
those syringes I know this is full of
[ __ ] bro what are you talking about
get first thing in the morning Earth sun
and steroids keep it natural baby
those are the three Primal tendons
he's really dodging the question huh
this is what liver King is he's you know
he he's posting through the pain as they
say it's very cryptic
yeah it's like dude the comments have
got to be like wild where was that
posted Instagram story so no comments
okay smart but I'm sure his replies are
like insane
all right well that's fun we'll watch
definitely gonna follow this story
as it develops but now let's get into we
have food that's rotting there which I'm
definitely gonna get [ __ ] destroyed
by how long has that [ __ ] been sitting
out now like two hours
oh one hour I can Vibe with that so
let's get to the warm quote unquote warm
food first
today is the long-awaited
influencer product review
I'm so excited to be here today
you know the cool new thing with
influencers is that
listen products is everything
um here we are at the discount this is
the Dollar Store come on
these products are worth more than that
okay wow
so I came home and went to bed yeah so
here
so here's all the products we have uh
let me pull up the list
here is the tier list at the dollar
store shelf oh come on guys they don't
deserve that
there's some good products on here
so let's take a look here's all the
stuff we'll be reviewing today happy Dad
shout out in Elk
Donnie is there donages in the can or no
I don't believe so okay that's not on
the ingredient list no Donnie
uh dreams uh
[ __ ] weird ass bracelet with baby
pictures
amaranth's fart in a jar David's Pizza
I did not know Addison Ray made a Barbie
but I do not like it at all
a phase up fingers face up
this is weird fresh and fit sells a
shirt that says who hurt you
oh the okay I'll get into it later we
have uh Emma Chamberlain coffee which
actually I've been wanting to try
uh bath water
hot Ones hot sauce
Jeff's Barber Shop products
oh well
whatever
conquer your inner [ __ ] this is Joe
Rogan official merch
so you can get that at what's the
website
[ __ ] on my dick.com
like high Primal yeah higher primals
higher higher primate conquer your inner
[ __ ]
Jordan Peterson bust of course uh benzos
are bust soy sauce
Beast Burger we there's so much maybe I
won't go through them all we'll just hit
them one by one but I think we gotta we
gotta do them relatively fast because
it's already 3 30. so let's begin Sam
thank you very much with the warm
products so I don't get food poisoning
this is exciting you know
so here we have Mr Beast burger right at
the top
um
did anyone else get some or just me
I got you got some
okay okay do I have a product cam here
yo you guys got to see this you got to
see in this box
oh I don't know I don't have that on my
phone what did you order from Beast
Burger Sam
oh my God you guys have to see this you
have to see in this box you need there's
been a lot of complaints I've seen
online on Beast burger no no no no this
this is next level this this is wild
foreign
it's Dan's phone that is normally the
handheld phone I can't see here
[Laughter]
that's the normal Beast burger here you
can talk for me Olivia
that's DB's Burger he said that is the
Beast Burger I'm gonna how small that
Patty is how much was this and then how
much was this Sam
it's like 11 or 12 11 or 12 bucks okay
and then it's like look at the look at
the accompaniments
he said look at the accompaniments
ever seen in my
Burger look at the Patty look how look
at the size of this thing he said this
is a double burger look at the size of
it look how small it is am I crazy am I
crazy
that is wild
you can yeah
[Music]
this looks like this looks like uh they
can hear me bring bring Lena's mic
closer and this is a part this is like
those ghetto burgers that your mom would
make you know when you were a kid and
you wanted something better
I'm sorry Jimmy this is sad [ __ ] bro
12 bucks
okay I'm gonna taste it
okay
that's
crazy
Beast Burger has two star reviews on
Yelp
That's crazy dude
oh no
they put sweet pickles on it
why did they do that I don't like sweet
pickles
why would they do that no they people
are saying that's a slider
it's not that's the Beast Burger
so it's got a slider Patty Mr Beast
Burger apparently operates out of like
ghost kitchens so restaurants will learn
their recipe so that Mr Beast Burger is
like not an establishment I know that
right so I guess it's more about like
whatever Place made that but it's still
really bad listen listen
and you're he's basically running a
franchise right you need to as the brand
regulate the quality of stuff that comes
out of there I'm not going to put it on
the ghost kitchen you know what I mean
yeah that's like you know it's like it's
like McDonald's they're all run by
different franchisees yeah yeah you go
to McDonald's anywhere in the country
you get the same [ __ ]
yeah
can you bring it closer and more down
actually that'd be good all right so I'm
gonna taste it
so here we go
sweet pickles that's a sacrilegious
thing to put
the tastes like beef jerky
tastes like beef jerky
someone said the tiny Burger makes my
hands look bigger well that's good
so I mean
the the meat tastes fine
you know it's seasoned yeah I hate when
people don't put salt in the burger
but look
if you're looking to order a hamburger
this is the last place you should do it
and it wasn't even cheap 12 bucks for
real Sam
it's fine honestly
but
if I pay 12 bucks for this and I was
hungry I would be very very pissed
but
it tastes fine
you know
it tastes like beef jerky but
I gotta be honest this I don't know this
has to be EFT here
maybe D because it tastes fine
but
I've never had food delivered to me that
looked that bad
yeah that's the smallest burger patty
I've ever seen sitting in a pool of
cheese
well the the cheese slices were like
twice as big as the
hmm
I think I think because it tastes okay
it's got to be a d
it's not a total f look at all this
extra bread
you see that
this is the circumference of the Patty
I'm ready to go I'm hungry
am I crazy or sweet pickles insane sweet
pickles are horrible am I a burger yeah
I mean I don't like them on their own I
hate them on a burger I'm not a relish
girl nobody does that
[Music]
Ethan forgot about the poppable
this looks worse than the poppable
I'm eating the whole [ __ ] thing
though
I'm hungry
what's the other food item
okay so I'm gonna eat this time this is
only food item
I'm sorry guys
I know everyone loves Mr Beast myself
included
but that's embarrassing
holy yeah
wow horrible
do you have any more by the way laughs
just kidding
you got a chicken sandwich cam yeah and
I ate it during the uh liver King
segment as an active Defiance
um wait what why didn't you save it for
the show was it for the show it was it
was getting cold so I just I just kind
of ate it um I just figured I would give
my review afterwards Cameron we got it
for the show I I ate it for the show
during the show we got to see the
sandwich okay mine was getting cold too
you know
well AB has the same thing why'd you
show it off oh
uh
maybe he just doesn't want to get food
poisoning again
oh that's the Miss Beast burger for the
hot sauce
okay well what's your hamburger look
like maybe
well I kind of destroyed myself it
looked like yours but I'm not eating
bread right now so
okay that looks like [ __ ] and how was
your chicken sandwich that you ate
before the segment cam
uh it was okay I think D is fair it was
like uh it was like the best
case scenario at a high school
restaurant uh High School lunch you know
I mean like it was it was the best day
at a high school lunch for chicken
burger
so it wasn't great but it was good it
doesn't sound that bad
it's something not something you'd pay
for it's something you're like forced to
eat yeah and I mean sorry you don't get
the visuals but it wasn't much to look
at it as well
all right I'll give it a d
moving on
okay so oh this is the soy sauce
okay so we did Beast Burger next we're
moving on to um Keith
from try guys is it just Keith sauce or
is it try guy sauce it's Keith's saw it
might be under the try guy name but it
is his sauce so let me go so you guys
can see the context here
okay now we're on as we know Keith is
the inventor of the soy face no hate to
him he's got lots of fans here so you
know we love Keith and all that
but it's hot sauce but we call it soy
sauce
so this is Keith's hot chicken sauce now
why is Keith making a sauce like
is he a chef um I actually know this
from watching them a while ago he has
like a tongue that he has described
it has like ridges in it that are more
sensitive to spice and because they do
like a lot of eating on BuzzFeed and try
guys and stuff he would talk about it a
lot and how does that help me he well he
made a hot sauce that is tastes good and
isn't horrible on his tongue so he made
a product for his tongue
and for others like his what am I
supposed to do about that my tongue's
normal
well maybe it tastes good you guys got
to see this chicken sandwich
I'm sorry but I have to show this oh my
God
how much was this chicken sandwich
15 for the fries and the sandwich
wait there's another chicken sandwich
yeah Sam got it for the sauce oh
so look at this
15 dollars
I can't see the preview or so you see
that
too close
Ethan is showing the sandwich
so tell me when you feel it's good now
watch this that's the 15 chicken
sandwich that's a bigger piece of
chicken than I got
and this bond is a nightmare this
is I'm not getting sit for like 12 of
them at Ralphs fries are horrible too
look at this
look how much ketchup they put on it
look at that it's like half a packet
it's like a mouse had a period sorry
sorry
about that
got that fresh lettuce
look at this
yo check out this fresh lettuce guys
that's all the lettuce
that's it that's all the [ __ ] red is
so put that on there
and then a grip of sweet pickles
fantastic yummy but those on there
this is the most sad this is the saddest
chicken sandwich I've ever seen in my
life this is
this is insane this is embarrassing
yeah that was a bigger one than the one
yours look better than this no that's
smaller than that one that was way
bigger if I'm Jimmy I'm shutting down
Beast Burger
your good reputation can't withstand
chicken sandwiches like this you're
better than this Jimmy
sad
I'm devastated by this
baby sad why would anyone buy this
fifteen dollars okay I'm gonna try it
and then I'll do with the sauce
oh
oh my God
you know when you taste really bad
chicken nuggets it's like stringy
it's like dental floss
it's like high school lunch right
this is prison
that's the f is moving down to F
this is so fun I would be so I would
return this I mean I wouldn't even touch
this [ __ ] this is so bad you guys
this is so [ __ ] bad
just is that an official call moving
into f
moving into F officially I'm moving to f
officially this chicken sandwich is like
Z it moves all of it down
what the [ __ ]
one thing I noticed Ian and I ordered Mr
Beast Burger when it first started and
it was actually good it looks nothing
like this like it came our Burger came
in foil had Mr Beast branding on it like
it it was it did not look like this at
all when I got one it was a big juicy it
was huge yeah it was like this big I
don't even think I could finish it did
they do a bait and switch on us
I don't know I I agree though I feel
like the quality control it can't be
snow quality yeah this is this is like a
Tyson's nugget
it's a chicken tender it's sort of like
just a chicken tender it looks like
somebody got the cheapest bun a Tyson
nugget in the oven
and just sent this to me for 15 bucks
Beast Burger made 100 million in Revenue
I don't know who the [ __ ] is buying this
[ __ ] they just love Jimmy I guess but
that's what I'm saying you're anyway
Keith
I hope your soy sauce can make this
thing a little better
let me try a taste of it so this is
Keith's
chicken sauce it says delicious perfect
amazing yes
and he's even making soy face on the
bottle so we love that for him
okay there's a hello Beast Burger in my
hometown there is mm-hmm
that's interesting that's kind of cool
yeah if it's legit
okay so off the
of the french fry and guy I'm not trying
to hate I'm trying to be fair as
possible to these influencers I'm an
influencer with the product you know
what I mean
this sauce tastes like [ __ ] [ __ ]
it just tastes like vinegar
like just straight vinegar try it I do
want to try it the one thing I'll say is
that it is actually hot it has a nice
spice profile it tastes like beef jerky
but in terms of flavor it just tastes
like straight vinegar of course
it just it's just vinegar
weird
really weird
but
still this sandwich is so bad it might
improve it so let's try that
okay damn I wish we had the camera kind
of
can you point it down more so ish
because I'm gonna make sure that people
can see what I'm doing here
can you lift it up and point it down
so people can see
yeah
what do you think did you shake it
before you used it yeah I think it it
was fine it really um it's definitely
more acidic than I thought it was going
to be I thought it was going to be
creamier it tastes like a spicy like
vinaigrette kind of I would someone try
someone else try this
here it's nice spices I think it's like
well done come dunk in there
go ahead Pam yeah
okay so Sam loves hot sauce so she'll
have an opinion on this
I agree it really does taste like a
spicy salad dressing or something I
don't know
it's not the worst but it's not that
great you've got good taste buds thank
you yeah go for it please I want
everyone's opinion on this one because
maybe I'm not the perfect candidate for
this I want you to show the food going
on there maybe you can get inside the
talk about these prizes sad soggy again
those are frozen fries they just like
put in the oven okay
yeah
sucks it sucks right it sucks yeah I
would never like it's just vinegar all
right I'm sorry okay
you don't have to hold it baby just
seconds all right so so okay but let's
put the um
let's put the sauce on the chicken how
much do we do is that I mean it's
chicken sauce so be generous with it
hmm
look at that bun boy
all right cheers to Mr Beast
I hate it everything in that I just I
hate it
I'm gonna eat it
the burger the sauce I hate it oh it's
happening
oh the only thing I could think was it's
happening
I hate that
the sauce look it's not my thing I don't
know what chicken spot sauce is supposed
to take like tastes like I've had lots
of hot sauce this has got to be a d
I feel like it tasted like a better like
more flavorful you know those like
watery hot sauces like like a Tabasco it
was kind it gave that to me but it had
more flavor I would say
it's got a nice heat that I like that's
what I'm talking about but the flavor
wise
I'm going to give it a d and the only
reason it's a d is because I like the
flame what do you think cam Sam
so I was trying to figure out how to
mute I think it sucks I give it I'd give
it enough but
I didn't think it was the worst but I
wouldn't buy it I don't know so there it
is not great that would be a I think I'm
gonna give it a d because I like the
spice I like the heat it's got a nice
heat level
[Applause]
other than that
I can't believe that Mr Beast Burger I'm
I'm shocked by that they really did a
hundred million in Revenue
yeah total revenue since they started
since they start oh my God but it was
good at one point
you know I think it's very um hit or
miss because the some store seems to be
horrible and I've seen like raw raw
hamburger meat yeah at least mine were
cooked [ __ ] there's a couple of reviews
up in the description I mean hit and
miss I guess
but the level of Miss that I felt on
that
okay there it is sorry Beast
I cannot recommend anyone buy that [ __ ]
all right what's next Sam
sorry oh Chamberlain coffee now this one
I've been waiting for I like coffee I
like Emma she seemed like a nice person
I like the the whole coffee thing
so we have this is the instant coffee
because we didn't want to have to brew
one live
so which one is it that we did this one
so this is Chamberlain coffee
roasted with love in California
100 organic
arabica coffee tasting creamy body dark
chocolate sweet caramel
caffeine strength five caffeine beans
coffee beans
okay Queen
let's do this so this is the instant
coffee and then this is I guess the
is this beans oh it's pre-ground so I
guess you just put it in your
that's interesting so was it like one
serving oh it's a bag
wait it's a back
oh
babe
have you ever seen coffee in a bag like
this like tea like steeping it
um I have seen that
um I think it's less common though yo
can you bring me a a mug a hot
water
and I think some cream to be fair you
know what I mean maybe
and a jewel pod please
all right here we go Emma
that tastes good
that's nice I like that
you know what I like about it too like
the packaging is nice
it looks professional looks polished the
one thing that I'll notice about Keith
is like bro this [ __ ] looks silly as
hell I'm sorry but
I'm just saying
no hate to Keith
but this packaging is really good
um I guess we're doing this a little out
of order so I'm trying to find
her
coffee maybe someone back there can pull
it up so I have to go through these
every time there it is thank you so much
so this is the um
yeah this is this is really nice
I can't see myself because the care list
is up
careless is covering and yeah
my laptop feed is gone
yes we are experiencing a technical
difficulties of course
would you say Zach
I'll just chill back with a nice hot mug
of Chamberlain coffee
foreign
scrambling
I'm slipping and chamberlink coffee it's
pretty good the camera's sliding back
looks like Zach got it there it is thank
you Zach
um
that's really good honestly for black
coffee which I I typically don't drink I
think that's very nice what's the price
that's that's an important factor
okay
here's from the Crimson Demon top L3 top
G rolls just kidding either my local
Beast Burger operates out of Red Robins
so the patties are full size
do you know where your Beast operates
out of yeah I think it operates out of
the back of a [ __ ] AMPM Red Robin is
makes a Killer Burger I like Red Robin
you're getting Red Robin for the same
price see that that's unacceptable to me
the consistency there is
[ __ ] nuts
foreign
so 14 for the whole box
and this one too
so I mean I guess [ __ ] is that is that
what do you think as far as coffee goes
is that it seems a little I feel like
it's not bad reasonable oh really
especially with how like well it's done
well this one has a lot of servings in
it and I like that
you know it's 10 bags and I like the
variety of flavors I'm someone that
likes to mix it up my coffee flavors
but this one's great actually I really
like it I think it's nice
mm-hmm
the one thing about Emma too is that you
know she's passionate about coffee it's
kind of been her whole stick since the
beginning so I like that about her
so which one should I go for next of the
careless cat blend that doesn't tell me
much
you know what I mean
like some more info because it's like
dog Bland special dog blend early bird
I like some details about what it tastes
like
let's do original family blend
all right
let's steep this [ __ ] here's the
packaging I mean the packaging's nice
instructions sit one single serving in a
bag
and a cup and add eight ounces of hot
waterproof for five minutes
okay
oh
I am
okay now I've actually never had coffee
like this before so we have the
a mug of hot water
we got our big old bag of steeping
coffee that's a big old [ __ ]
tea bag that's a big old Tea Bag Boy
also there's cold brew instructions
which just says refrigerate it for 12 to
24 hours okay
interesting
all right let's try this one good so far
though really good
anyone else try it
I'm sipping on the uh instant coffee
right now it's nice right I'll dig it
yeah yeah it's pretty good
I'll read some donuts as I wait for my
coffee to brew
Runner says go to Urban skillet for
their incredible Burgers I mean okay
tell Mr Beast that
um
Riaz Khan says LOL at their tier board
so casual I love it all right
thank you everybody
I I I've never been so disappointed by
anything that piece Burger man
[ __ ] me
the beasts are uh taking a dive man the
liver King not a beast Mr Beast
I like Mr Beast but how do you sell this
[ __ ]
it's just embarrassing
didn't you and Mr Beast go to the Burger
once
did we get a beast burger
oh yeah in and out in and out yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah now that's a [ __ ] bird
in and out I like you know what I mean
and it costs like four dollars for that
I'm not listen I'm not I'm not I'm I'm
like Jimmy
I'm not trying to say I don't like Jimmy
I like Jimmy but I'm not gonna sit here
you know what you mean that was a
nightmare dude
all right this looks ready looks pretty
dark
so let's let's see uh Emma
can you oh can you put the previewer on
the screen so I can I I like to see what
everything looks like over there
all right cheers
hmm I like to see yeah
so I'm gonna put some half and half in
there just to be totally fair
because I usually drink my coffee with
cream no sugar
like I like my men
that's what people say right
two creams no sugar like I like my milk
thank you and a little bit of seam and
floating milk corn
all right cheers
mmm that's that's a fine coffee in fact
I'm gonna bring this home for Eli I
think she's gonna like it
I love it I think it's great I just
tried the Instinct it's very good it's
really good with the cream it really I
gotta say I can like it I like the
coffee
I like it Casey just donated 20 bucks
and said least lurger you could have
taken that 20 bucks and got yourself
a gram of beef from beef burger
not the dog pound on beefs but come on
so Emma
I'm gonna drink this damn coffee too
show me the tier list
yeah that one's going up there man it's
hard to say s because I haven't
interact I mean I like it it's
definitely a at least
I'm gonna put it at a
and potentially we're gonna be
uh upgrading that as the
segment goes on I think it I want to see
how it compares to some other ones
what do you guys think I mean a I mean s
what do you what what does s even mean
like I'd uh I I'd put it at a B
it's better than B I really like the
[ __ ] s honestly the like all of it
the packaging the art the taste of it
was awesome
yeah I think her marketing is really
good too
the price is good Sammy said yeah I'm a
Stan what can I say are you an Emma
Chamberlain Stan yeah so I needed that
information that's critical as you are
but I just leaked it yeah you're biased
passion project plus quality people are
saying equals an s
[ __ ] maybe I'll go s I just I just I
don't want to bust my load as they say
so quickly on the S
I'm with the A and B
you haven't you having a the coffee you
know what do you think I really like it
it kind of reminds me of Turkish coffee
I really like the flavor and the
consistency and I'm drinking it black
right now which I normally don't and
it's still really good you want to try
with cream I have a few here sure by the
way I just got a Dono from Timothy he
says the Beast Burger near me operates
out of food town which is literally a
grocery store and it's very bad
[Music]
[ __ ] me it's also worth noting that the
coffee here isn't uh acidic at all too I
don't feel like it's like I like that
yeah I don't know if some people like
acidic coffee but I like it's very mild
in a good way I love it
let's keep it at eight for now just for
now I don't have any complaints though
we'll see maybe I'll move it up
[Applause]
so thank you Emma okay a strong entry we
love that
what's next oh the boys from now
we got me a happy Dad
at long last
okay perfect
all right we got ourselves a happy Dad
it's a Vibe right now
the official beverage of jerking off
your dog
so let's see this is five percent
alcohol
this is fruit punch flavored
says with electrolytes white don't try
to sell me that [ __ ]
you know what I mean it's a hundred
calories which I think is pretty pretty
standard
it's got a tiny bit of added sugar
roofie sold separately roof and roof is
sold separately at happydad.com
now what does it mean happy Dad what
does it mean dad's happy he's not
beating the family tonight because I'm
the cool I mean like that when he's
sober he's dangerous
Jeffrey Dahmer's happy Dad
okay I kind of like the packaging I'm
not gonna lie I like the simplicity
or like you go it's not bad I'm gonna go
cow Style on this
here we go
everyone else grab one that wants one
smells fruity
hmm
interesting
could really taste the alcohol
I find it interesting that they've
really
they've kind of reimagined what would
considered probably a feminine drink
and they turn it into the boy's drink
and these are alpha males right I'm
gonna send it
what do you think of uh this Packaging
Is that real yeah
they partnered me I don't like it at all
for a limited edition banana wait they
really partnered with the with
unfortunately sad but true
why
money why
foreign
have you guys seen happy Dad in a
grocery store somewhere where alcohol's
sold uh Ralphs oh they actually hold it
there yeah so they're doing pretty good
yeah I I really enjoy those
I can't lie it's actually pretty good
it's refreshing it's not it's not over
powering in my opinion
I like them no that yeah
I don't want to drink a lot because I
don't want to actually feel the effects
of alcohol but
it's not bad honestly I could see myself
getting down with these
start
um turn the [ __ ] up with some happy Dad
not a bad product I gotta tip the hat to
the uh milk Boys on this one I'm being
honest you know what I mean now not the
hugest fan Beast I like
being honest
it's pretty good
not even gonna hate
yeah I like it anyone else
just Zack
I'm not crazy about it yeah I mean yeah
but it might be the fruit punch flavor
I'm I don't know do we have other
flavors or just this one
it's not very uh
I don't know like compared to a white
claw or something it feels a little more
uh light in a way like seltzery it's not
very girth I don't know is it so it's
competing with white claw right yeah it
I don't know that it's better than white
claw it's a little closer to uh what was
the uh cat the Travis Scott one oh
cactus cactus flavored to me then and
that's not a good thing see I don't know
I personally I'm not a huge fan of white
claws I find them to be a little too
sugary and I feel like this is a this is
less sweet yeah it's almost not sweet at
all it's like a Lacroix with alcohol
yeah which I personally like I don't
like sugar in my alcohol right
you know I like I think I'd give it a b
honestly it's fine as far as influencer
products go it's it's good
I think The Branding is good I'm
impressed that they got it into like
ralves and all these places
I I I'm impressed you know what can I
say
thoughts what do you guys think
I think the C or D
it's okay it's not a d come on I don't
know I'm just not I don't know about it
maybe I'd have to try a different flavor
but uh Sam said the Beast Burger in
Colorado Springs literally gave me food
poisoning
he seems really cool but he legit needs
to close his restaurants I agree I I
don't think I honestly think
this is
not a good situation with this food it
is really really bad someone on the sub
posted what their fries look like I'm
sending it to you oh God I can't wait to
see
oh my God I just I've never seen food
delivered that badly
holy [ __ ] that's what they got
it's supposed to look like this no shot
no shot
and I'll be honest this is my reaction
when I opened my food it wasn't that bad
like can you what's the burger the
double Beast Burger look like on their
website
looks [ __ ] delicious yeah I want to
see compared to what I got
I mean you can't do this bro you're
you're using your Goodwill to sell slop
too are they gonna box that up
this one yeah it doesn't even make sense
not really realistic it doesn't even
make sense
uh it's just it's kind of [ __ ] up to
sell this [ __ ] it's not even barely fit
for consumption
there's so many horrible reviews online
and pick disgusting pictures
and yet people keep buying it
wait can what's the B yeah yeah I want
to see what the hamburger is supposed to
look like
well what did uh
[Music]
oh my God you've got to be kidding me I
mean this is false advertising like like
this should be illegal
I'm sorry let's get PNP back on it's
just it's just not right
it just gives all influencer products a
bad name it's such an obvious cash grab
there's he doesn't give a [ __ ] about it
the quality of food I got makes me want
to spit you know on the food promo
pictures they add like WD-40 and like
listen
I get that
is Jimmy the beef King
was he the beef King I guess in the same
way liver Kings deliver came
he's taking steroids in his
average promo pictures
ew
said me love it's gnarly dude and
there's another beef burger literally
the chum bucket in real life
at least yeah but I'll say at least oh
my oh my God that's Raw oh my oh I'll
burn why would you deliver that why
would you send that out
cook another one you know that it's
super interesting because these ghost
kitchens are working on their own margin
and they're like they don't even know
the [ __ ] I am they're gonna be like
Jimmy
so they send out the most dog [ __ ] food
I think there's like too many of them
there's too many Beast Burgers you know
it needs to be only a few I feel like
that would help but we need to control
quality yeah what were you trying to say
love go ahead so that's raw beef that's
one thing check the picture below that's
raw [ __ ] I sent another one Discord
that's raw chicken yeah at least by the
way they he got like a normal sized
Patty [ __ ]
he can cook it he should have a full
meal well would you rather have that or
a small Patty I'd rather have mine
at least I could eat my photo okay raw
chicken that's a crime that's horrible
that's a crime you cannot serve this
food
funny story about the chicken burger yes
it was mine I never got a full refund
really
dude
I'm gonna Yak I'm gonna get my chicken
don't do it oh my God I took a bite of
that thing
good thing I had soy Keith's vinegar to
destroy any form of life on it yeah
cleaned you up from the inside soy Keys
Auntie salmonella serum
it's the perfect topping for Mr B's
chicken sandwich
oh my God
it seems like more consistently bad than
decent here's another one are you even
finding these love
oh this is very easy it's fine I'm just
Googling at Mr Beast Burger we have two
levels of doneness Smoky jar and still
moving what how do you serve that
like how like how do you serve this
I think some people just do it they're
doing it for fun they're just they're
working in their regular jobs kitchen
and then they're like I have to make it
for a different
no I'm not fun with this I would I would
have a little fun
well listen obviously Jimmy's not the
one cooking the food but like in terms
of a business model it's not working
holy [ __ ]
and they don't even send them in these
cute little boxes anymore either so what
exactly is his involvement I got it in a
generic box it's not there's not even
The Branding anymore
holy [ __ ] dude
love just keeps sending them I can't
look at this I'm gonna look at this last
one and then be done
yeah I thought the one I got was
unusually bad but it seems like
mine was unusually good
I got a good one
if you ever thought about trying Mr
Beast Burger don't not only is it just
bad but they're every aspect of each bit
in the wrong order the b style fries
came as microwaved Oreo fries
but nothing else on them and they also
won't refund
I find that really interesting that they
won't refund that doesn't look that bad
looks charred to [ __ ] [ __ ] better you
better than what the [ __ ] I got
I mean it doesn't look good
I just I think it's so fascinating that
they won't refund either who's buying
this
I guess there's enough Beast fans where
they can each person can buy it once and
decided they never want it again and
still makes money
all right let's move on so so I'm gonna
put Happy data b i I thought it was not
bad I can't I cannot lie I cannot tell a
lie like uh George Washington or whoever
said that
I'm basically George Washington
Jeffrey dahmers
all right up next we have um
yeah can you pull up the tier list cam
thank you
up next we have dreams
simp bracelet this is one of the
weirdest things I've ever seen in
Creative so
members only slap bracelet you know
who's in the slap brace it's my
three-year-old son he loves those
[ __ ]
slap bracelet how young are your fans
dude
with flash drive and special dream
content two-week pre-sale
yeah I remember when he dropped this and
I found it just really creepy he has it
with content includes baby pictures
chapters from dreams old books childhood
emails old Gaming screenshots pics memes
from dreams camera roll and more I mean
I find that so creepy
how hard he's playing up the parasocial
relationship
combining the fun of a slap bracelet
with the utility of a USB drive
no thanks
so I don't know we don't have one of
these do we
we don't even have one no those are rare
very rare how much are those on like
eBay or do they are they on sale or can
I buy one aftermarket
yeah someone said what the [ __ ] is
childhood email that's my that I'm so
confused about all this baby pictures
seriously I'm not seeing anything on
eBay you want to send your baby pictures
to fans why
baby sad
so weird
so I mean in terms of influencer merch
do we be able to find any of the
pictures that were on there
no I looked for those two I can't find
them super rare
so you can pull up the uh tier list
please
in terms of
influencer merch I bet he sold a lot of
these [ __ ]
34 bucks for a slap bracelet you know
that [ __ ] costs like 10 cents
we were trying to buy Theodore one
because he really wanted one and you can
only buy them for like a thousand at a
time wait Theodore really wanted one
yeah he was not that dream one just
like he doesn't know who dream is though
I was like not yet damn you think
he's more blippi
he's a blippi boy right now I love that
[ __ ] also Steve and Maggie if anyone
knows that channel rules that's my fave
we watched Steve and Maggie together and
they don't even try to sell babyhood
baby pictures to my son
what's the chance there's pedophilia on
that
on that Zip drive
it expressed by a percentage
five percent maybe 100
five
there's a reason it's super
right and the FBI actually gathered them
all not fit Prima consumption
um I don't know how to even rate this
it's just weird like it's not for me
it's for his fans how do you rate this
even it's just weird am I rating it from
like a universal perspective or like
I mean it's an F right it's just [ __ ]
weird it's awful it's horrible it's low
effort he bought a bunch of them from
China put a stick on them put some [ __ ]
it's just it's awful and it's 34 it's
insanely expensive for what it is it's
[ __ ] gross
and you have to be a psycho to sell this
I'll just be frank
fact
it's so weird
that I don't think I could ever forgive
him
I think I have beef with with a dream
it's that bad
someone says look into blippi's past
yeah I'm sure that guy's up to some
weird [ __ ]
all right what's next
let's see next up we've got the uh of
course the amaranth
farc
in a jar
now obviously this gets points okay so
this is 17 out of a thousand we have
we're there actually it's memorabilia
which I appreciate
um and it's authenticated as well 17 out
of a thousand how much were these do you
remember the price like 200.
we did she sent it to us right yeah a
thousand bucks and it came with a piece
over here
is there a piece of hair in here
oh yeah I see it's a small one it's
really small
am I gonna accept this smell on this
probably right
Zach already did that and he didn't
smell anything so but there's no sand
I mean in terms I like the concept it's
funny it's ridiculous
um
you know
I I think I think she's she's riding the
path that Bell Delphine blazed to be
frank am I right
she stands on the shoulder of giants as
they say Daddy
but um
I appreciate the boldness to fart in a
jar
I guess I'm gonna smell it God damn [ __ ]
me
do I have to smell it can someone else
do it
you do it maybe we'll do it and don't
lie don't lie about it
last time you you embellish
Lina you do it you'll be honest would
you do it Lena yeah okay Lena will do it
should be honest
thank you Lena of course
yeah be quick though you gotta be quick
with it
[Applause]
oh my god really yeah
how long ago did we even get these wait
wait so it's got to be funny business
you must have put a fart you want to
smell oh it's probably gone by now maybe
I'll smell it I'll smell it uh It's
gotta be like a oh there's a fresh one
here
leave it contained the scent the snow
but wait then then that makes me think
that she didn't actually fart in it
but it smells like afar I know there's
like fart spray but it's
oh we opened the first one I didn't
smell [ __ ] you want to try this one Zach
sure I'd rather you than me
didn't we how could it hold a fart for
that long
that's what I'm saying
good job Lena suck that right down
appreciate that
nothing
put your nose right in you got it says
Lena like she got all the way in there
nothing nothing
sorry to disappoint no I appreciate the
honesty
bummer dude wait but someone said Dan
said uh before blippi was blippi he was
a YouTuber and apparently pooped on
someone
I don't know what the [ __ ] that means
he's dope though
it's apparently true I just Google it
what does it mean he pooped on someone
you know I just sent a piece of text
there blippi [ __ ] on people yep
read the last part
um
blippi did the Harlem Shake and pooped
in another man's butt no joke he really
did that
thank you Eddie and our R-rated twist in
the 2013 video that BuzzFeed news has
viewed
Stephen blippi John takes an explosive
diarrhea [ __ ] on his friend's nude ass
in a truly shocking rendition of Harlem
Shake are you
can you find that I want to watch it off
screen no shot that blippi was blasting
diarrhea on his friends before he was a
child Entertainer
BuzzFeed has seen the video
that's posted on BuzzFeed news
send me this I'm going to watch it off
screen I won't and I'll try to find it
wait I got it I got it I got it what
oh all right I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna watch it
dude what is wrong with you dude
I'm not letting my son watch blippi
anymore
Harlem Shake poop
look at this
wait I want can you guys not hear the
Audio I muted it I think the audio is
fine well the Harlem machine yeah oh
okay okay
so he's on the toilet dancing to the
music
he is in like a really low income
bathroom by the way I just watched it
yeah that was a nice thing
okay so he's he's popping he's got a
Helm bicycle helmet on for some reason
and now his friend okay so his
okay
hold on hold on hold on
dude no no you should be banned from
entertaining children after that
why does this dude blippi what the [ __ ]
how did he project that much that's a
juicer that is he has a juicer [ __ ] just
loves
what the [ __ ] is happening
um it's kind of impressive okay so let
me describe it to you guys so
he's dancing on the toilet and then it
just cuts to his friend
with his legs you know over his
torso so like his ass is up in the air
he's butt naked
and [ __ ] he's got oh Ela good I wanted I
love it I'll send this to Ila send it
can you someone says she just wrote in
chat she said are you [ __ ] on me
right now flippy what
hold on hold on someone Ela I want you
to watch this and then maybe just call
I'll send it Paul Lina or a B because
I'm using my phone
yeah so
his friend is on his back with his legs
up
and his [ __ ] is out he's butt naked
and blippi uh projectile diarrhea is
onto his for all over his friend from
about two feet above and he's smiling
and looking at the camera
drippy blue yeah there's distance there
and and actually as I look at it
there's both chunks and liquid
and they put down a tarp on the floor
because colors they didn't want [ __ ] on
the floor but it was so explosive that
it actually still got on the wall
and the towel
why why did they think this was funny I
mean this is so vile
they even made a website Harlem
shakepoop.com
they're selling T-shirts too this is so
[ __ ] disgusting dude you are
not right you are not right in the head
who is this blippi guy
he's a he's like the most popular child
Entertainer on YouTube oh really shut up
yeah but you don't know who he is no
okay wait let me show you who he is so
you can understand why this is so crazy
blippi
he was watching it right now by the way
she's gonna call it this is blippi okay
just to show you
[Music]
about blippi he does he goes hey
everybody it's flippy everybody join me
in the creatorium
Bellevue Washington this is good
which way are you in the bathroom it's
all like yeah well did you watch the
video Ella mm-hmm
oh my God does it get louder I'm still
quiet hold on Milo
this is the iPhone oh yeah yeah you
watch the whole video
I watched it and I kind of wish you
would have seen me I audibly gasped and
then just stared at my phone with my
mouth off and open
I couldn't move it has to be and it's
him I recognize him yeah it's him oh my
God
do you think it has to be some kind of
fetish thing to be willing to [ __ ] and
be [ __ ] on like he's got to be in the
sky
oh my God I don't know what I why do you
go into children's content up to that
how do you pivot from that
yeah so they didn't even know who blippi
is I'm trying to show them like look at
this pink pink it's pink guys Brown
[Music]
green guys
is color green yeah he's very popular
and I don't know that we could watch him
anymore
no yeah
I don't think that's one of the most
vile things I've ever seen in my life
and I've seen a two girl one cup tub
girl it's up there do you know what I'm
I'm trying to oh someone says put it on
Twitter can we put that on Twitter just
literally if you look it up it's the
first thing I mean I kind of feel bad
doing that so here he's probably tried
to bury it bro he's the one that [ __ ] on
his friend what the hell I've been
letting our kids watch that [ __ ]
can we put that on Twitter or we get in
trouble
love you're the expert It's like because
it's like shocking it's not like normal
porn it's like shocking vile porn yeah I
don't think they [ __ ] I would not yeah
yeah I don't the [ __ ] is is so it's
touchy I played safe right now yeah okay
isn't enough for that [ __ ] it's a bear
it's apparently easy to find yeah yeah
people want it they can see it
all right wow blippi's off the menu man
describe my reaction
you know other than like shock I'm just
disappointed in him
literally shaking I'm crying I'm
cheating
somebody says wait someone said Ethan
you forget we showed PewDiePie on it's
just reductions that was worse what did
I show him
what did I show him we did that collab
video I remember I showed him something
[ __ ] up I remember what
what I don't remember wait it up blippi
originally uploaded that video to
YouTube
yeah it says that it was removed after
two hours
here's a headline
and then it says should I let my kids
watch blippi even though he made a viral
video [ __ ] on his friend
what year was the Harlem Shake video
because I'm seeing he started blippi in
2014. so that was one year later oh my
God that was in 2013. natural transition
but that that kid doesn't care about the
kids that dude there's supposed to [ __ ]
on people
like
his kid content is so good
yeah he's good at it you know I know
yeah he he did a bunch of prank videos
back in the days too and that's kind of
the same uh transition as all the pranks
are doing yeah Elsa and Elsa and
Spider-Man stuff yeah yeah oh my God
all right blippi blippi made a boo-boo
what do you think man just keep this
[ __ ] off the [ __ ] kids channel okay
we're about to be finding like hidden
like that Balenciaga campaign we're
about to be fighting like hidden bottles
of [ __ ] in his videos and stuff I can't
wait for all these kids to find this
video one day
they're gonna be like what though it's
like when all of us thought that Barney
said the f word this is like 10 times
that he sold shirts apparently Harlem
Shake poop.com and brown
[Music]
the website doesn't even exist Ian
no I watched it on a web archive
it doesn't work yeah
yeah it's from the Wayback machine
I think the FBI stepped in
took the domain off
all right uh thank you for calling you
I'm sorry about that well we gotta keep
we gotta keep looking on but thank you
so much thank you for the 10 donation
that means a lot to have your support
yeah thank you for your support a huge
fan of the show thank you thank you
thank you appreciate that I'm doing it
with the show of course anything for the
fans
all right all right see you later bye
I think it's safe to say the Harlem
Shake poop shirt would get S tier on the
back merch yeah merch
um one sec here
alrighty
um
well amaranth's fart in a jar it's Hit
or Miss bring up that the
the tier list
sorry apologies for this but
wait the mouse voice is off is this all
the way up
oh this is too slow for me
I'm gonna put Amorous at like maybe a c
because for just the meme Factor but if
half of them are getting fart smells and
half of them are you know what I mean uh
you we need confort consistency you know
all right moving along
we have dough Bricks Pizza which we
don't have right
those are only open from like three to
ten or some [ __ ]
we gotta try to get that just put it in
the fridge or something and then we'll
do it the next day we'll skip that one
for now
Addison Ray Barbie this thing is cursed
as [ __ ] am I wrong
oh we have it
so where'd you buy this
so it's not in stores not at like Target
yo this doll is cursed as [ __ ] look at
that
who's buying this
do kids want to Addison Ray doll
I bet I wanted a special Barbies when I
was a kid
I liked them it's not a Barbie though
it's like a rip-off
doesn't matter if it's not a Barbie
brand I think that the young yeah you
think the four-year-olds can tell but
they know
they're like this ain't Barbie this
ain't Mattel it's not Mattel brand
the box is kind of cheap feeling too I
don't know that maybe it doesn't matter
but I don't know how do I rate this so
it's it's horrible it's horrible Addison
is passionate about female
entrepreneurship
oh you know what she gets exit points
for her crazy ass dad
and has built a multi-platform business
which now spans social media music
cosmetic fashion acting who's this for
the three-year-olds creating and
building businesses are things that are
very important to me and a part of who I
am I hope I can Inspire other girls who
want to be entrepreneurs live your life
love yourself
scan here for a special message from
Addison Let's scan
I need their special message from
Addison on that one there
[Applause]
foreign
apparently I don't get copyright claimed
but
female entrepreneurship is one of my
core values and it's really been a
driving force in everything that I do
building businesses that are authentic
to me and who I am
is part of my brand and it's something
that I encourage everyone to try and
pursue it's not always easy but I really
encourage you guys to try and make all
of your wildest dreams come true because
anything is possible when you your mind
to it love you guys
[Music]
that's it and one of the [ __ ] scan
the kill for that [ __ ]
he had to learn how to use a phone
I mean okay
I I think it's a d i mean I'm obviously
not the consumer here
but the for me
I'd give props to her like well I guess
personal level that's probably like a
dream come true for me to have Zach
Lewis action figure doll that is yeah
dude I [ __ ] love that
but look at her okay let me open this
let me open it I mean you know what I'll
give her a d but C because simply
because her dad is so crazy and she made
it despite that
you get the Monty bump also young gravy
blanked her mom which is vibes
look at the face it's just not
it's just not it can you see that
I can't see it can you can you show it
on my previewer
all right it doesn't look that bad on
screen but
really [ __ ] up when I look at it all
right it's a c
let's Mount slam through these damn I
really wanted to try dobric's [ __ ]
Pizza
[Music]
shame we'll get it now we'll get it soon
right Sam yeah yeah yeah yeah good good
good good good good
all right
moving on here
Let's see we did this we did this we did
this
do we have the phase up finger okay
whatever stupid skip this is for the
this I don't get this I mean okay face
finger it's like I don't know see I mean
I like the idea I like the finger thing
with the phase up it's kind of clever
and fun I'll give it a c
I don't have the finger though so
now this one is so weird this is fresh
and fit official merch
and it says it's a girl saying who hurt
you
Who would wear that
like genuinely it's also not even that
cheap for like a basic tee with a print
one hit print 38 bucks
I mean that's an f i I don't care
imagine they sold any of those
that's F no effort you should read the
uh product description there too
description the standard response
anytime facts are spoken to females oh
yeah okay but why would you wear that
shirt right like it's not even clear
whose side you're on
are you on their side or your side it's
because you need to read the product
description to understand the shirts
doesn't make sense it's an after it's
literally a reflection of how dumb they
are actually I have a theory they always
say merch whenever they're getting [ __ ]
oh the focus all [ __ ] up but yeah
anytime like they're in a debate or
something or someone says something to
them they'll be oh merge merch we need
to put that on merch so I I guarantee
you they are probably in a corner at
some point we're like well we're gonna
make that to merch yeah we're gonna they
went they went the dub we yeah they went
this far just to not be embarrassed Emma
thank you for the five gifts appreciate
you God bless
that is F2 man
uh moving down we've got Emma which we
did
Bells bathwater I mean she's the
original originator of this as far as
I'm aware it's clever
I like the whole thing I give that a b
from a pure novelty perspective hot
one's hot sauce so we have this
it's good I mean the products are good
you know
I give that an a the packaging's insane
the products are good these guys know
how to do it man
hot Ones hot sauce definitely an a
at least
in fact they might even be asked here in
terms of like presentation and stuff
that's really good it's at least an a
Jeff's Barber Shop we have Jeff's
Barbershop products
now Jeff used these on me and I was
super impressed with the quality of
these when we did the show
Jeff's Barber Shop
shake well spray into damp or dry hair
style as desired you want to try it Amy
because you have hair actually and
you've all right sure I'll try it and
also Jeff said he was going to give me
and Zack some of that he and I can't
yeah go ahead
I don't want you to he gave me and I and
I it was okay I just want to say I can't
help but notice you had three boxes in
your car today I I really meant to give
those two he gave it to me for you guys
uh so that may have been my bad thank
you Jeff
so this is a texture spray smells really
nice okay Ethan
you like that smell yeah
yeah so he says Shake
it says Shake okay
spray on the damper dry hair so just
hair
style as desired
okay
I can't see myself but it smells great
yeah you can see yourself right there
I don't
I mean my hair was kind of already
I'm just gonna keep spraying it
uh the description is this sea salt
texturing spray adds waves body oh I
actually I do like that a lot you see
that I don't know I don't know if I'm
putting too much but I like what it did
for you my hair's pretty short I just
cut it but I do like the sea salt spray
because it does make it you know easy to
uh Style
I mean it feels nice doesn't feel heavy
it says body and volume to hair while
leaving a subtle Sandalwood scent Jeff's
Barbershop texture spray is an everyday
staple for an efforts effortlessly sexy
look just by thinking man not this guy
not this guy advertising my my hair
product why because I always got my own
hair is always messed up but I mean
I don't know feels good smells good I
feel like I just walked off the beach
that was really good actually and then
there's a
cone which you know I like Combs kind of
cool I like it and then there's um
clay Palm Pomade this is what he used to
make my um
and um
I like the packaging is really nice
actually
clay pomade
pretty cool that I'm actually really
impressed with what he did here smells
also very good what do you think
yeah it smells great
that's a big thing the smell oh yeah
definitely
it smells like [ __ ] it is the same scent
the sandalwood
if you want to move on to the next one
and give me a few minutes in the
bathroom I come back with a with a final
result what I want to watch I I need to
like clear out my hair because I already
had product in it that's why
okay yeah go do that but it smells good
it seems like a good product rubbing
hands rake through hair I mean
doesn't seem that complicated Maybe
oh is that you think good
shout out Jeff love that guy his texture
spray is amazing Bella Simmons okay I'm
doing it here
oh it smells so good actually I'm gonna
I'm just gonna do it for Jeff he's my
boy
oh I think my hair's supposed to be wet
or something that doesn't feel right
I think it's supposed to be kind of damp
rub in hand right through here probably
doesn't matter
it's for both
I think you're putting too much you just
need a little on your fingers glove in
it I think I used too much you guys
he put glue on your hair
you might want to take some more
actually I smell good I mean it looks a
nice wave happening it actually looks
kind of good right yeah
what do you
water
dude it smells really good
I'm liking this look kind of a vibe
I think it needs more
[Applause]
also Loki bringing out the colors
I see the pink
I feel like the smell is so good and I'm
gonna put some of this on too
foreign
what do we think fantastic
you survived
it comes with this comb
has the durability on that thing
this test stress test it flexible nice
I love the color
let's use it oh yeah it works
you see how it Combs
I was asking if you can comb it to the
side
I'll try and part it yeah I'll try that
I'll try I'll try
so like this
okay my hair is very unruly I think you
guys don't appreciate
what a difficult oh wait
I'm all backwards
I don't think you guys appreciate just
how hard it is to style my hair
but it's working
what do we think
it's really hard in the camera preview
it looks good
if I just say it like that
because I'm surprised that it looks good
ab my boy slicked back and ready to [ __ ]
you know I gotta say I feel different
too I feel different I put it in my hair
also oh did you oh so you don't need me
we smell good no I always wanted to see
your hair no what I like about it is
that it's firm but I can still play with
my hair it doesn't look like it's like
glued to my head and I can still move it
around you can still touch it yeah you
still style it some products it's like
you're playing with
just try it dried [ __ ] yeah no
not this no but I really do like it come
thank you thanks baby I like it I think
it's a great product smells good I'm
super impressed that he was able to
put this together packaging is super
nice
I'm a fan what can I say
what do you think is it an a
I'd argue it's an s
why
because it's it's everything
I can't I'm good I can't listen I love
the product I can't put this above
hot ones or Emma I think it's on the
same level it's our highest honors in a
right now
I think I'm looking for some X Factor
I'm not aware of yet it does smell so
nice I'm smelling babies here from right
here it's top tier though it's top tier
it is okay Ethan
sorry Jeff I I it is it's close to an
ETS I agree I just don't know where the
S is yet okay so you're holding off I'm
holding off but you think it's an S
that's good to know yeah
okay let's move on actually the one I
really want to try
I'm just going to skip some of this
really dumb [ __ ] because we're running
out of time
I really want to try the prime I've been
waiting
to get my hands on oh the feastable
cookies let's do this yeah let's do them
in order just the ones I gotta rinse my
hands off because they're a little
sticky from the product hold on
this is my favorite Jeff product
s tier the mugshot mug after Classic
after using this product I kind of have
the confidence to just be on here and
Host this if needed
it's life-changing wow I want to take
some of that home that Jeff should yeah
there's some for you yeah
anyone here from Arizona all right hell
yeah baby there's catching Gators in
Arizona
what are you put in your hair today
besides a hat
what's going on baby my hair isn't all
not you at all oh nice love what's
looking pretty fly oh really thank you
thank you wait is that a hair yeah
something about Mary look going on how
the [ __ ] did you do that I have no
product in my hair no shower this
morning I can do this All right so I've
tried uh so we're moving on all right
we're moving on somebody already broke
into this
oh thank you you didn't try it
did you like it cookies for you oh Sam
loved it okay so
so maybe we're gonna have a Mr Beast
Redemption product
Sam said it's s tier
but no uh cookies for you
so here's Mr beats beasts cookies
chocolate chip plant-based
plant-based what does that mean there's
no there's no milk in it no eggs no egg
no milk really so it's a vegan cookie
wow
well that is interesting
okay vegan cookie
hmm
got a nice like vanilla smell
they're vegan
for a vegan product that's very very
very good
um
[Applause]
foreign
you like that huh
oh
this is gluten free also
oh my God
that's got to be the best
gluten-free vegan cookie you can get
my mom can eat this
my mom can eat these
dubrick
that's very good
that's a Redemption moment right there
you guys do you guys want to try this
hell yeah sure we'd love to pass those
around
I mean the vegan
um gluten-free product Market it's hard
to make good [ __ ] in that in that
section
and I know because my mom eats that
stuff and it's usually just so bad
that is a [ __ ] good cookie man that
stands up there with even the
gluten and dairy cookies I'm gonna bring
that I'm gonna bring that for my mom to
try
oh
Doom never in a million years would I
buy a Mr Beast Burger but I feel like
I'm gonna buy these regularly this is
yeah yeah
what's going on there I recently figured
out that I may have a gluten allergy too
so Sam's kind of been my gluten Mentor
this is uh this is really good and I
haven't had a cookie in forever so God
bless the texture is really good and the
flavor is so sweet it tastes kind of
like birthday cake or sprinkles but you
don't expect that because it's chocolate
what makes you think you have a gluten
allergy
I've been trying to figure out what's
wrong with me forever
um oh really it's really red and my ears
get really red
and um
the well-known Flocka face that I make
it's sort of like a stress tick and
definitely eating certain foods makes it
worse
and Sam was describing her symptoms and
it's similar with like the red face and
red ears so I haven't been eating it all
week I've been bothering Sam like all
day like could I eat this
and so far so good oh really yeah oh
Guru Sam
good luck on your gluten-free journey I
serve people saying Oreos are vegan are
they also gluten free though
because that's the trifecta
my mom can eat those cookies that's a
big deal
Oreos aren't gluten-free sadly here's
what I'm gonna say open the tier open
the tier list so
the product is asked here but I think
the branding is not good
because if I saw this at the grocery
store I wouldn't buy it I wouldn't think
that it was good
and if you look at the back it's kind of
missed like the photo of Mr Beast is
kind of weird too
like he's just like a little he didn't
look that into it I could be mistaken
but doesn't this look like the packaging
of another popular cookie
uh Sam do you know what I'm talking
about
saying there are gluten-free Oreos okay
because I thought maybe it was
intentional to make it look like that
right
I don't whatever it is I don't like it I
would not buy this
and can you get can we get a close-up of
the Mr Beast picture he just he looks so
not into it
on the back it's like kind of funny you
really got to do this from his face
show me yeah I mean it's yeah it's like
I don't believe him
so I'm gonna give it an a because the
product is amazing but the branding
could be better
you guys all agree with that
impressive though I didn't expect that
after that Beast Burger my expectations
were pretty low
now let's move on to the chocolate bars
we've got
Mr Beast Redemption Arc we've got the
you know what else I like about his
cookies too I will say I like that he's
like
making a food
that
is inclusive in that like people with
allergies and there there's a lot of
people out there that can't eat that
[ __ ]
uh I think it's I think it's Brave and
Bold to go for that market where
everyone can eat it and it's good so I
like that
here we have the
original chocolate
almond chocolate
and quinoa
quinoa quinoa crunch
quinoa
and as we were talking about that me and
Ila in Israel they say quinoa so that's
why we're so confused about it our
quinoa quinoa
so I'm gonna try that quinoa crunch
how much were these they're cheap I like
two bucks a bar or something yeah
I know if I'm smelling Jeff's product or
the chocolate
I mean
chocolate's hard to elevate
for two bucks
the quinoa crunch
yeah I like that crunchy texture a lot
it makes a big deal about
there's only five ingredients
which is funny because if you look on
the back of those cookie ingredients
there's some wild [ __ ] in there
bye
I don't care about all that stuff
doesn't bother me
just sugar chocolate liqueur
cocoa butter
crispy quinoa
sunflower lechen
tastes good
you know a farm
this is the Almond one
it's getting all keyed out crazy but not
on your camera
I mean
look at the original I didn't even try
that I'll be fine
it's like chocolate
I remember trying it before I didn't
like it but it tastes better this time
the Mr Beast bars have a certain
Nostalgia for me because that was the
birth of uh Zoe zonka
oh right
I think the bars are like probably
B
I mean it's cool
good price tastes good
you say b as in Beast B is in B's yeah
it's good it's good I like it
those cookies are off the chain though
yo can you get one for my mom
you had a sandwich went crazy just
ordered 12 bags
I'll take I'll take a bag when they
arrive
how many more
okay Mr Beast Redemption more chocolate
left burgers
I'm not reviewing all of her stupid ass
Cowboy tears boo
okay Prime let's do this finally
these are cool they're cool
all right so I've been actually super
eager to try this Prime
they made this to compete with
Gatorade Powerade all those guys right
and I personally
I used to love Gatorade as a kid but as
you get older you realize you're like
this is just sugar and salt
got some quinoa in my mouth in my throat
Okay so
yeah so it just tasted kind of gnarly to
me and when you look at the back as an
adult when you're thinking about
calories there's actually a lot of
calories in
Gatorade and it's kind of gross really
so here we have Prime tropical punch
and what's interesting is it has 10
coconut water
thank you for the prime
gluten-free caffeine free
so the ingredients is filtered water and
then coconut water
that's so interesting 25 calories so
it's low calorie which I like must have
some kind of artificial sweetener
which again don't bother me
right
uh they have all it says Prime was
developed to fill the void where great
taste Meeks function
with bold thirst quenching flavors to
help you refresh replenish and refuel
Prime is the perfect boost for in for
every Endeavor we're confident you'll
love as much as we do humbly the prime
team I don't know that humbly is the
right sign off
like
what I don't really give a [ __ ] but
thanks for letting me know humbly
coconut water
I don't know what the [ __ ] BCAAs are but
apparently there's 250 milligrams of it
B vitamins antioxidants and electrolytes
okay whatever you say
let's try this [ __ ]
damn you gotta be a you gotta be jacked
up in the bottle
[Music]
now I'm a strawberry
yeah
oh it's sweet too sweet wow it's so
sweet
it's sweeter than Gatorade
oh no I was expecting a like this it's
way too sweet let me tell you I really
like it I really like it too the blue
one's my favorite yeah I do like it the
red one you don't think it's too sweet
the red white and blue popsicle one it
tastes like a melted you know those like
rocket pops but they have a red white
and blue flavor yeah
did you you like the red one it's so
sweet I didn't try the red one I like it
yeah the blue one though I like it's my
favorite I've only had the blue one all
right let me try this it's really good
it's so [ __ ] sweet I can't believe
you guys don't think so
my dream for a drink like this is that
it's not so [ __ ] sweet
so I'm kind of at a uh you want me to
make you a cup half water half Prime
that I would like better I think I would
like that better I'm not gonna do that
though thank you for offering what's the
point of reviewing that
chat says do you think Logan knows what
color those bottles are no he needs he
relies on KSI for the color now these
glasses have changed my life
and then the green the lime what's the
price on these is it like
competitively priced or what
oh the lemon tastes like piss bro the
lime
it literally has a piss aftertaste
please tell me you don't
someone taste this
it has a piss urine aftertaste
I'm being honest look I I came here
really expecting to like crime
I'm not taking up dude what the [ __ ] did
someone pee in that
it's so pee-ish Logan sends his regards
you just got silly songs again
are you serious
yeah this tastes like yellow Gatorade
yellow Gatorades one way to call it
someone please try that how bad do you
have to pee right now
it tastes like um a melted popsicle like
those little ice popsicles all right I'm
in the middle two better but yeah I mean
I don't hate it that doesn't sound good
though a melted popsicle try it Lena
please
you're honest uh you you Ethan Ethan's a
tweak
okay I like it it's really sweet you
like that it's really sweet
interesting well the good thing is that
at least
it doesn't have a lot of calories that
one has 20 calories so
you get your fix
whoa I think I'm in the minority I don't
like it
they should collab with uh blippi for a
[ __ ] flavored
it seems that I'm in the great minority
chat loves it too so
listen I already I've been giving good
reviews to to people
I got no bearing on what I think about
them
but holy [ __ ] I don't like that
so let's go to the scoreboard here the
tier list
uh Hannah says hello family 2016 I put
up Vape Nation sign behind President
Obama Vape nation was on the news crew
check out Discord
[ __ ] too
no so it seems you guys like it so I
don't want to influence the ranking here
too much since I'm in the minority like
what do you all think about it
Prime uh Olivia's saying a I say a
I say B I'm gonna let's do a b then
because like first of all I respect so
much what they've accomplished it's
amazing the market saturation they've
gotten already maybe it's an a it like
makes sense for him you know yeah maybe
it's an a I I don't want to be overly
hated hating I think it's pretty
incredible honestly every time I go to
Target it's sold out yeah I've heard
that people are going crazy it's my
friend's boyfriend's favorite drink he
like brings it home from the grocery
store all the time
people love Prime people love Prime so
and it's fairly priced 1.99 per bottle
that's good price
so I'm not even gonna hate I'll give it
a a even though it's it's not for me but
I respect I respect what it is so there
you go
all right Logan
James Charles whatever okay now this
one's special Tana's dizzy wine
Tana we couldn't find the daisy wine or
it took it took a while to uh get it
delivered right
and I have to give a special thank you
to Tana
I reached out to her
and told her we were doing influencer
product review and Sh and we we were
wondering if she had any because we we
weren't going to get it in time and she
had
um a case of it
is it well she she had a case of its
posts or she had it ubered to our office
uh right before the show started really
nice so hopefully I I don't hate it
excuse me
your hands look massive
what do you mean it's a normal size can
just one thing off the bat
um
for something this size to have this
much alcohol in it it's 13 alcohol which
is the same as like a Four Loko 12.5
that's like a bottle of wine in this
little thing
no it's not what are you talking about
yeah that's the alcohol content of like
a bottle of wine
yes it is
a bottle of wine this much wine this is
this much and the amount of alcohol in
it is much more what are you guys
talking about it's 12 and a half percent
alcohol the fluid in here is 12.5 worth
of alcohol I'm saying it's the
equivalent to a bottle no it's not what
do you think it's percentage by volume
yeah yeah what literally what are you
saying right now I don't even understand
the logic what do you mean so if a Jager
Bomb is 35 I mean if Jaeger is 35 a shot
of Jaeger it's the same amount it's just
wine if you take a bottle that's 13
alcohol and pour that it in this can
it's the same wine I don't know about
the wine
I don't know about that what
you're saying I'm getting dizzy man
Olivia are you okay well you guys are
confused they didn't teach you guys this
at private school content in this is
higher than excuse me most drinks this
size it's wine it's the same higher than
normal wine no this is the normal
alcohol content for wine it's 13.5 12.5
percent
so it's just a little wine it's just
wine in a can yeah I don't know what you
got I don't understand the logic going
on here hey man I'm trying to understand
it's just wine put in the can hey you
guys been juicing too much man you know
what I'm gonna give it an S because it's
making us [ __ ] dizzy already we
haven't even had any oh is it called
dizzy because it's supposed to [ __ ] you
up I think so oh this is the red one so
um
Tana said the one thing I ask is that
you serve it cold so it's been in the
freezer this whole time it's nice and
chilly it's nice and cool
this is the red wine
12.5 alcohol which is basically like
drinking a full barrel of Everclear
according to Zach not what I said
no it's four of these cans equals one
bottle of wine that makes so it's like a
glass of wine yeah well exactly yes but
it's
yes it's a glass of wine
yeah does that make sense are we on the
same page yes okay okay whatever you
want man but you don't you don't believe
me no I believe you
I still don't really I'm just trying to
understand your logic though I I did I
don't know I'm dizzy I'm dizzy okay okay
you got your dizzy on them
because you thought it was like said
okay whatever I'll move on Chad said
love is enjoying watching The Americans
that's funny
so this is the red wine 12.5 alcohol
oh yeah
okay from Napa County from Oakland
bottled in Oakland
it was grown in Napa I don't see that
that's what it says below red wine
oh no oh yeah Napa County okay cool and
how much was this is an expensive
product
foreign
is this carbonated or is this wine
it's just wine
it's nice I like it did you guys got the
red wine yep
how many cans come in that
that's kind of pricey
45 I mean if it's good wine I don't know
why it's expensive
I guess
because if you want it to taste like
kind of good it does taste really good
yeah it's nice and smooth as far as wine
goes it's nice I mean you could
definitely get [ __ ] up on this I'm
used to manishevit so I mean anything's
better than that you know
this is actually really good at a party
at school last semester they had these
and white Claws and these get you much
more current than white claws yeah
because again
right one of these is probably equal to
two white clothes it is that is true
yeah
you could crush one of these so easy
um it's really good actually I could
totally see myself
going weird and wild with this
um
yeah I'm about it I've gotten weird and
wild with this the white one really so
yeah that's the first time I'm trying
red though it's good I don't want to sip
too much of this because my ass gotta
drive home
it's okay
you'll be good yeah we're good I'll be
like one of those those tick Duggars
gotta enjoy your freedom boys this is
what you do when you get home from work
yeah
um
I could easily crush this and be drunk
in like five minutes so you know David
it tastes really good okay what's that
you'll be in a David P Tick Tock it's
all good
my great client here
got [ __ ] up on disneywine too much
wine crashed into oncoming traffic
with wine sorry I really like it if I
was drinking I'd want one of these I
think better than happy Dad
but the one thing that happy Dad does
have because we had to buy this from our
website right
so the happy Dad convenience factor of
being in the grocery store
someone said bro this is so long thank
you for the content oh they I thought
they said this is too long I was like
stop watching
they didn't say that though thank you
for watching
Tyler
[Applause]
update on Abe's Porsche long yes
better the doctor said it's okay oh you
went to a doctor yeah I went to the
doctor yeah because the comments scared
the [ __ ] out of me I thought my that
doesn't take a piss my dick was just
gonna fall off so yeah good I went to
the doctor so did you go to a dick dock
didn't go to Dick doc because last
minute I just went to a family doctor he
went to an Urgent Care thing yeah new
drop trowel
a little bit did they touch it uh they
said
yeah they touched it he handled it with
or without gloves with gloves yeah okay
good
you know what Heather told me once and
this kind of blew my mind some
gynecologists don't put on gloves have
you guys heard of that I've never heard
of that okay that's [ __ ] crazy I
don't know if that's the Israel thing
but it scared me and disgusted me and
freaked me the hell out as weird as [ __ ]
okay but good oh so so apparently in
America we wear gloves we love that
whoa I like it but so what I was saying
is that it doesn't have the convenience
factor that happy Dad does
that they're in routes
and I think they're I don't know it's
really good though I would definitely
drink this over happy Dad in fact
how many of these do we have I'm gonna
bring this home and get blasted tonight
sure oh we used them all [ __ ]
it gets a little pricey
she's like [ __ ] 20 bucks
I'll pull up the tier list
I think it's an a it's really a good
product
it's a little pricey but wine is pricey
you know
I think branding's good too too much
wine sorry
I like Tana too she's a friend of the
show
so there it is Dizzy's nice a lot of
good products actually I'm kind of I'm
surprised there's more
seems to be more good products than bad
products on this list
um not a lot of f tiers but there's a
lot in the eighth here
Yak jerky unfortunately we didn't get
any time did we buy it okay oh yeah I
want to try that yak jerky
uh I don't know nail polish oh okay then
the grand finale
Beau blacks are boy Boby you guys he's
better known for his sound bites go
ahead Zach
you have nothing
talk about the allegations
yeah so talk about the allegations is
actually a competitor I would say for
this year's zombie tournament
and recently
Bobby had a really base tweet about my
Vatican take
the quartering at keemstar were trying
to get me banned as you guys know and
Bobby my boy tweeted out nobody is going
to b word the V City on behalf of Ethan
Klein stop being such snowflakes let him
joke about be wording the Pope
I thought that was such a based Boby
take
because he's in there with those guys
you know he he's friends with Keem for
some reason
and uh
we realized that Bobby I wanted to
express my gratitude to Boby not just
for the Great Sound drops but for his
unyielding support right
uh Bella Simmons 20 bucks for either
this dizzy wine
you are you rich Bella like what's going
on here you're loaded damn
love that for you thank you
Phillip says he take that to 12.5
percent
yeah so I wanted to express my gratitude
to one of our biggest and unyielding
fans Bo Blitz
and so we realized that he's selling a
plushie doll a neckbeard plushie doll
which is pretty brave to actually put
this out there don't you think with the
neckbeard and everything
and frankly there's nothing more than I
want to cuddle up with a little bubbly
dog
at night to comfort me neck beard and
everything
and he's only sold 56 of them sadly you
need to set you need to sell at least
200 to fund the uh
the doll very sad about that for him
because it looks really good I wish Dan
were here for the liver King story yeah
we'll get his take on it next week
he actually um
here's the website he made a video
promoting it
here you can get the plushie doll for 28
bucks
I don't know what this means plushie
plus product design download link
emailed to you what I need the [ __ ]
AI file
what am I gonna do with that it's like
the deluxe edition you know they add
like the the music with the game if you
buy the deluxe it's like that oh and
he's got a Twitter uh bird because he
reads tweets love the back of it for
some reason just like the hair is like
just a [ __ ] disaster bro but I love
how honest it is
and it comes with a comb what does that
mean
s
it comes with the comb
uh
I think that
might be a ruler yeah probably oh Emma
just hooked me up with the Disney fund
thank you Emma
and so um he put out a video on YouTube
trying to promote it and here it is uh
this is my boy again Boby uh stalwart
fan of the show
ing me now over the past six months I've
been working with makeshift to make this
plush a reality and now it's finally
here and you have until the end of
November to purchase it if we get 200 of
these sold they will ship out if not you
will get a refund so if you want to
support the channel in any way I highly
recommend getting one of these rather
than donating or getting any other type
of merch because I want to make sure we
get this in people's hands by hitting
the 200 unit threshold he also comes
with a free Twitter bird that you can
take off and on and you can have me
sitting right next to you
reading tweets some people think the
neck beard is controversial but I feel
like it's accurate to me I'm not gonna
false advertise that's about I like the
vibe man
might as well anyways I wonder I want to
support the channel if you're interested
buy my plush
buy it
you boy
[Music]
my question is does the doll stink
really bad
I don't know about we I'm just saying it
looks like he smells from that I mean
with peace and love and maybe it's the
Dizzy talking I don't want to be a dick
it doesn't look like he smells good am I
wrong for saying that
I don't mean to be an [ __ ] but dude
okay whatever I don't I don't want to
get stuck on that so anyway Bobby uh he
made this plush doll
and he sold only 56 of them and he needs
200 more
and what today's the last day of the
month so how much time is left on this
let me open this
he's tweeted out he doesn't think he's
gonna hit the goal this is so sad
I'm so sorry Bobby he says
uh it was from a week ago I already know
that I probably won't hit the 200.
and everyone will get refunded doing the
giveaway through the plush is more than
a way to ensure that a hardcore bullblux
fan gets 500 instead of some Rando so
he's giving away 500. there's there's
nine days left 14 hours oh there's nine
days left yeah
crazy bro
how do you even do that play that again
like literally 500 you're on another
level bro
yeah he says I'll be giving away 500 to
a random person who buys
remember that because that's important
yeah so he needs how much more does he
need to sell 144. he needs to sell 144
at 28 bucks so how much money is that
four thousand thirty dollars
well I'm proud and excited to announce
that day in honor of our boy Beau box
who's the star war star war most loyal
fan a Defender we are committing to
buying right now Sam is processing the
order a hundred and
44 bowblex plushie dolls let's make a
reality
it's happening you're my boy
and now we're gonna have 140 bubbly
plushie dolls all around the office we
got who knows what we're gonna do but
it's gonna be good I know what I'm doing
with mine this what are you doing
why what are you gonna do with that oh
nothing I just I'm gonna hang it up in
my room what are you gonna chill like a
voodoo doll and stab with noodles no no
Bobby's my boy
yes do you have the receipt Sam how's it
going over there
it's processing I want to see that
website update and say funded
[ __ ] the shipping is 579 oh no
so how much am I paying spending total
500.
oh no the shipping is 600 bucks but it's
all going to the same spot
it did it go through so how much did I
spend
four thousand six hundred dollars on
bubbly
I don't know if it's the wine but I feel
like that was a great purchase I feel
proud
send us the receipt would you let's go
to the website and see if it updated
there's nothing I want more than a bow
blacks plushie dog
yes 201 sold it's 100
[Applause]
thank you for your support kimster I
would never do this for you in fact I
doubt he's in that five thousand dollars
laying around his broke ass and um just
remember
you're the man bro and uh I will let you
speak and I will talk about the
allegations which is that you're a
totally cool dude
let's go that's right I told you
[ __ ] I'm willing to waste money
on dumb [ __ ] and I'm just oh it says did
we get the discount though Sam because
it says get 15 off if you buy over three
something I said it was still five
thousand bucks oh my God
I was like yo we got a 15 discount for
three how much do we get for 144. man
you better get that 500
that's why so yeah that I read that
tweet I says Bobby I want that 500 bucks
bro oh no wait you gotta buy the plush
and retweet this tweet should I retweet
no I'm not retwinning [ __ ]
[ __ ] give it to someone else I'm not
retooling your [ __ ] bro
[ __ ] that
oh [ __ ] that
oh my God
yeah so so I don't know what should we
do with the 444 Boby dolls you guys
[ __ ] it's gonna be so much fun a
giveaway yeah we can give them away I I
have I have an idea I want to see how
many Jimmy Lee could flip on the street
that's just my fantasy I'm just curious
how many can sell yeah we could take
them to the live show they could all see
it they would love it what if we try to
flip these into a profit yeah oh my God
let's sell them at the live show because
if we sell them at the live show it has
lore because I know I'm getting a little
buzz from this dizzy and I've only had
like a tenth of this [ __ ] I mean let's
go nothing Juiced getting juice grape
juice you could put them on stockx
yo we should for sure sell those at the
live show
what can we do to them to make them
special where we can mark them up inside
we can sign them just sign them yeah
just sign them silent reselling signs
Bobby plush dolls wait will we have them
by then because ourselves unfortunately
I don't think so I believe it ships in
March but maybe since you got this March
Yeah March can we refund that
is it too late to charge back that [ __ ]
maybe since the goal ended early perhaps
it could be made a little bit quicker
Bobby can we speed things up here I
won't need to flip these
it says March 5th yeah it's not
happening
did Bobby tweet about you I know he
watches no I'm on his Twitter not yet
Bobby come on bro this is big news we
spent five thousand dollars on your ass
for a joke passed out he said
oh no no those are old
we can make like a pre-sale we don't
need the items to sell them let's just
put them up immediately yeah and for on
our website for a hundred dollars in
fees I'll donate the money so it's not
like I'm I'm profiting wouldn't that be
so funny
mark up the Barbie dolls bro
Chad said this is what happened it
happens when Dan's gone I know this uh I
appreciate y'all you know uh you guys
made a good effort to keep the show
going today I know it's not easy so
thank you everybody for helping float
the boat here yeah but it was a fun
episode it was really nice
yo for real let's let's let's let's
resale those
in fact what if we put him on stockx or
something just for the laugh and our
fans will buy them but it'll be on stock
eggs
like how funny is that
oh my God
yeah we'll figure it out are we really
how long we've been going
we have been gone almost four hours
three minutes having too much fun here
maybe it's just dance and I here
no well Dan would have rightly told us
to wrap it up an hour ago
because it's already 5 15 my ass needs
to get home it's it's scary without Dan
yeah but okay so we're gonna figure out
how to how to flip a profit on these
Bobby dolls I think that's got to be our
goal one or the other 100.
I know it's so funny it's just it's 500.
all right guys I hope you had fun today
oh I just got a donation for the bobi
fund thank you Casey
appreciate that
there's nothing on this
um receipt right Sam no
makeshift thank you Sam claim your badge
four thousand six hundred dollars
four thousand dollars on 144 Bobby
plushies I can't believe they even let
your buy Audrey and 44 of them shipping
600 bucks
this is something in it
that's only that's more than we've spent
on the Scorpion chair I think
I'll take them oh the Scorpion chair was
more you should put the baby dolls all
over one of our chairs yeah we gotta
just put them in every shot you know
because we have so many so every shot
just means full of both me dolls
oh you should put them in like just
random Teddy fresh orders
that'd be kind of funny unless
um
we can we can make a better use I think
we got to resell them
how much do you think I could get for
one of those on Street
signed or unsigned assigned whatever
fine I think you could you could make
something I don't know hunt more than a
hundred
probably not if it's you and Ila maybe
so if we do it 100 if we flip 144 of
those for a hundred each you're looking
at 14k
10K profit yeah garyvee style flipping
it's 14.
bro that would be so funny we have to do
that we have to do that let's see you
know what I'm sorry I'm gonna cut you
off but I'm gonna say what if we all had
a certain amount and see who could sell
the most like uh like a like a book fair
type thing
oh [ __ ] that is so funny we're totally
gonna make money from Bobby's dumbass
plushies
we are totally gonna flip this [ __ ] and
we'll give it buy one someone says
they'll buy for charity so there you go
um
oh my God
this is one of the funniest things ever
all right this is gonna be great anyway
guys thank you so much uh it's been a
joy it's been a pleasure
someone suggested start a multi-level
marketing scheme with his Plushies that
could work I could I could see that
happening maybe we should buy more I
don't know if 144 is enough we're gonna
be flipping this for a profit
we need to invest you are feeling that
invest now while we can
ah
yeah maybe dizzy is S2 you know what I
mean
let's move the Dizzy up
all right guys thanks everybody we'll
see you tomorrow morning for an episode
of leftovers and uh look forward to that
we got a lot to talk about tomorrow
and on Friday as usual thank you to all
of our members
thank you to everybody in the audience
we love you and thank you to Bobby for
inspiring us every day and for just
being a faithful viewer and defender of
the H3 Nation you would be the Pope in
our Vatican City
and I would I wish I would never do any
cause any harm there to you or the city
itself so thank you everybody and thanks
for watching see y'all tomorrow morning
Tata foreign
[Music]